this is jocko podcast number 240
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
and also joining us tonight once again
dave burke good evening dave good
evening all right last podcast
which was podcast 239 in case you
couldn't subtract
one from 240 and i suppose we should
give out some kind of shout out to the
240 golf i don't know why
but we should shout out to all you
machine gunners out there
that that ran that 240 golf last podcast
239 we covered the
first edition of combat lessons
rank and file in combat what they do and
how they
do it that was number one and
you know to be honest when i got done
with that one i said you know that's
cool there's but there's more of them
and i kind of thought to myself you know
well uh
how many combat lessons are there right
and then i remember this is 240 podcasts
worth of combat lessons
but i was leaning towards hey probably
not going to cover more of these things
because there are more of them
and then i started reading number two
and as i read number two
kind of out of the gate section one
which is called leadership and you just
get
you just restart reading it and before i
knew it i couldn't stop
and there's more lessons more
perspectives more angles some more
knowledge to make us better
and i was really coming at this one i
was really thinking about life
a lot you know all aspects of life
and i think it's the opening of this
that gave me that
sort of mindset going through it i was
thinking about life the parallels are
everywhere
all right let's let's go to the book and
i think dave coming out of the gate
you're gonna realize where i why i got
so
sucked into this thing just out of the
gate so the first section like i said
it's called leadership
and then and then the first subsection
is leaders versus inertia
i was already i was you had me at
inertia as they say
lieutenant colonel r e o'brien cavalry
observer with the fifth army in italy
here's what he says
in spite of the fact that i observed
many interesting things in practice
in the practice of tactics and technique
still the one lesson that stands out in
my mind above
all others is the one that is so well
known by military men
that its statement here amounts to
little more than a platitude i mentioned
it however
because it had such a profound effect
upon me
that lesson is the importance of and
need for
adequate leadership so
cool i got through that fine i wasn't
quite there yet
and then i read this the effect
on most men of the impact of battle
is to cause them to want to do nothing
a determined effort must be exerted to
accomplish even simple tasks
and men are likely to neglect duties
which they know
must be performed so think about that
right right out of the gate right there
the effect of men in battle
is that you're going to want to do
nothing and again this is why i was
talking about how this started
making me think about life a lot think
about that
when it comes to life how many people
are just drawn
towards the easy path not doing what
you're supposed to do
duties that you know must be performed
but you neglect them
yeah that's that's the difference
between success and failure in life
by the way did you guys say in the
marine corps
why why stand if you can sit why sit if
you can lay down
did you guys say that in marine corps
similar what'd you guys say uh
i'm trying to think of the phrase but
it's the same alignment of like
why do this when you can just do that i
can't remember exactly what i said but
when you as soon as you said that
you were saying i was a little thrown
off by the title because you said
leadership versus
inertia and i was thinking myself
leadership kind of creates inertia
and when he's saying stan the people who
follow like newtonian physics are going
to
laugh me out of the building but it
seems like what he's describing is the
opposite of inertia sitting there doing
nothing rather than moving in a
direction
yeah yeah or it's the you're you're
fighting to keep it going keep the
inertia moving yeah
uh he says there is no force other than
a driving leadership to overcome this
inertia yeah so he talks about inertia
as the static
being not moving this tendency to
carelessness
and to infuse a determination to succeed
in the minds of the individual men
when this spark of leadership is present
the individual knows that others feel it
too and that his effort is not alone
however
i was not a leader in this campaign so i
will quote an
officer who is a successful commander in
an infantry regiment
the wearer of a silver star an officer
who has a fine reputation
in his division and here's what this
officer says
this tell your people when you return
that the hardest job they will have here
is getting things
done my men know their weapons and
tactics thoroughly
my effort is simply to require them to
do the things they know
must be done posting security
dispatching patrols seeking a field of
fire retaining their equipment
and making sure that it is in working
order you have to check all the time
i believe it was patton that said
90 percent of your job as a leader is
making sure that the orders get
executed making sure that the things
actually get done
so that opening right there is what kind
of made me just say
i we need to talk about this because
it's it's applicable so directly to us
as human beings
and you know i always talk about the um
the gravitational pull you ever seen the
chart of the gravitational pull of when
the space shuttle or
something launches i guess it's not the
spatial it's it's space x
sure elon kicking those things up into
space
but they use whatever some massive
amount of their power
is to get the first whatever mile up
that's where they use 50 of them i don't
know what the percentages are but it's a
massive percentage of the power is to
break free
of the gravitational pull of the earth
and once they're free of it then once
they're moving they're okay
like so much of the effort of a leader
is just to
get things to go get things to move
and we're going to get to this there's
definitely some things here and we're
about to roll into them
where it talks about you know
so much reliance on the leadership and
in certain situations you can see them
leaning towards
a micromanagement you know hey if i
don't make this happen
but in other parts of the of this book
they start talking about how
the way that you're going to win is
through individual efforts and
individual leadership so you get into
decentralized command a little bit later
but
but i think it's one of those
dichotomies i think it's one of those
dichotomies as a matter of fact i know
it's a dichotomy
that sometimes the phrase i used to use
a lot and i use it a lot on this podcast
was the force of will right hey you know
as a leader
i'm just going to make this happen
there's going to be a force of will we
are going to win this thing we're going
to go this
i'm going to make this happen and that's
what he's talking about here this
force of will that you have to exert to
make things happen
even things that people know they should
do
next section discipline so right out of
the gate we're talking leadership and
discipline
i was i was in there the keys to success
in combat
the key to success in combat commanding
general
in a personal letter to lieutenant
general mcnair i would like to mention a
few things i consider important in
getting
any prospective units ready for duty in
southwest pacific the first
of all requisites is discipline with a
capital d
i refer to discipline in all its phases
water discipline malaria discipline
personal appearance
military courtesy the wearing of the
uniform
personal and collective sanitation
carrying out orders
in general assumption and proper
discharge of responsibility throughout
the chain of command
etc there is an inclination for men
as well as some officers to go native in
the tropics
to let down mentally on material and
spiritual values
so discipline is especially needed here
needless to say i consider an aggressive
offensive spirit always goes hand in
hand
with good discipline
so that's that's one of those things
where you know we're talking about
imposed discipline
in some ways there right you make sure
your weapons are clean make sure you're
cleaning yourselves makes
there's a there's a whole list of things
make sure you're drinking water make
sure you're cleaning your feet
isn't that a weird one have you ever
been in the law in the water or in the
in the bush long enough to get like a
really bad feet
no i got i got a minor case of trench
foot yeah
and when the guy who is my swim buddy
during this particularly
long snr operation where we were a
two-man pair out there
just a training operation but he got
actual trench foot he got
he went to medical and they're like oh
yes you have trench foot
it's weird that things like that you
know
when you see talk to guys about vietnam
one of the main
things that the officers would do is
check guys feet because they wouldn't
check on themselves
so even something that seems so
obvious like you'd want to take care of
your feet
people will not make that little extra
effort the inertia
for them is to say you know what i'm
just gonna go to sleep with my boots on
and they're wet i'm not gonna dry out my
feet
and by the way you can sleep with your
boots on i did we would
we would sleep with our boots on the
field but we'd take our socks off we'd
unlace our boots
so our feeder and they're just kind of
loose so they can kind of dry out a
little bit
hang your socks on a little tree or
something nearby
but you don't want to get rolled up
echoes looking puzzled you don't want to
get rolled up in the field without your
boots on
okay that makes sense if you get rolled
up in the field without your boots on
you've got some problems to deal with
i can see that btf tony you know you
take one boot off
you fix whatever you got to fix then you
put that boot back on then you don't
take both of them off
you're just sitting there john mclean
style basically
naked oh yeah that's uh a movie die hard
the first he runs on the glass yes he
wound up running over glass and how come
he how can we get caught without his
boots on
because when he arrived at nakatomi
plaza
he at um a request another quest a
recommendation from a friend
you take off your shoes and you make
fists in the carpet with your toes it
de-stresses you
so that's what he was doing in the
middle of this hijacking scenario
interesting yep see there i was thinking
that this book had knowledge in it
uh next lieutenant colonel clifton
f khan 77th
field artillery in italy the great
stress placed upon discipline and the
chain of command
is not an overemphasis and never can be
we have found again and again that the
highest standards of discipline are
absolutely necessary
in and out of combat in no other way can
you be assured that the individual
soldier will
carry out orders without supervision and
in combat this is essential so again
we're talking about
very stringent discipline and we're
talking about imposed discipline
i mean we are let's call it like it is
yeah but the connection he's making is
is what i was thinking
as you're talking that last passage it's
that connection to the imposed
discipline that i'm going to start with
that's going to get you to recognize
over time yes
what you need to do the self-discipline
you need to create and if your plan is
like i'm just going to make my folks
self-disciplined
you're actually going to skip the part
where they learn why you have to do it
and sometimes that starts with
you're going to do this you can ex
explain it
but you asked me if i ever had an
emergent foot or trench foot i never
spent enough time
in the right an environment to have to
deal with that but i'll tell you my very
first
fortune forest march which is a five
mile for smarts like a very short first
march at officer candidate school
in 1991 we stopped 50 minutes into it we
all changed our socks
that's what we did and so that's one
example of
but it was totally imposed on us but i
was able to make that connection
from these other people and so you're
telling the story about people that
were non-combat ready because of that
but those lessons are
all over the place in the military and
it all starts the same way which was
sit down take your boots off change your
socks and then over time you make the
connection of
oh i understand why i need to do this so
no i never had it but
i was taught that lesson very early on
yeah there's um
some sort of obvious religious overtones
too of right of like taking care of your
men's
feet right that's just a powerful thing
next the basis of good discipline one of
our problems has been to get junior
officers and young ncos sufficiently
hard-boiled to exact from their
subordinates and meticulous obedience to
every order
we must ingrain in all ranks the
realization that orders are not to be
treated as suggestions but as concrete
facts calling for the utmost effort
until they have been carried out
so many people seem to feel that orders
which are
inconvenient or unpopular are to be
disregarded
and this is this is one of those things
it's hard for me to read this because
we're always telling people look the
military is not this thing where just
someone barks orders at you and everyone
just obeys
which it's not this state of mind
is a disease and must be eliminated so
what what this section says or what this
individual is saying
and i don't know if this is the same guy
talking because it's not broken out
but then it says this then it says this
on the other hand so we got dichotomy
and elimination presupposes that all
commanding officers and staffs take care
that the orders they issue
are consistent correct and capable of
being carried out
so so that that's a very a very discreet
way of saying if you give me an order
that's
not consistent not correct and not
capable of being carried out i'm not
going to follow it
that's what that says they do it in a
very roundabout way they're very
cautious about how they said that
because they know they had colonel pogue
in the room when they were writing this
yeah
and colonel pogue said these better need
to listen
because colonel pogue comes up with the
best plan every time
master your job lieutenant general
walter krueger
discipline and and the leadership of
small units are the things which require
constant emphasis the enlisted man or
officer who does not follow instructions
and orders
implicitly during training or prior to
reaching combat
areas and who cannot do everything every
member of his unit might have to do is
not properly qualified
the squad leader must know exactly what
each member of his squad should do in
each type of operation
the platoon leader should have the same
knowledge concerning his squads
and the company commander of his
platoons officers must not
start worrying about the big picture
until they have mastered all the details
of
the little one it's an interesting one i
can tell you right now that
it would be impossible to know
everything that the sniper knows it
would be possible to know everything
that the radio men knows it would be
impossible know
everything that the point man knows it
would be impossible to know everything
that the breacher knows
do you need to understand them yes
should you be able to
set up that breaching charge and clack
it off if you have to absolutely should
you be able to pick up that radio and
make comms if you have to where it might
take to communicate it may take the
radio men
four seconds to do it it might take you
three minutes should you be able to know
how to do it yes
at some point if you're worrying about
the details of the little picture
you might be doing a disservice by
thinking too much about the little
picture not enough about the big picture
so i think officers should start
thinking about the big picture from day
one
and understanding how things fit
together now you can't get lost in that
but you gotta you gotta start thinking
about it early
otherwise your habit is just worry about
the little things your focus becomes
looking down and in instead of up and
out
so little that one's too strong for me
too strong for me and i talked about
that in leadership strategy and tactics
like
you kind of know what to do but there's
a
there's like a very discreet place in
the military where
you go from being tactical they call it
operation but
where you start being strategic in in
the marine corps it's called
being a company great officer which like
a junior officer brand new lieutenant
to a field grade officer yeah and all of
a sudden there's this magical moment
that when you get promoted
from in the marine corps it's captain to
major and if it's in the navy from
lieutenant to lieutenant commander well
all of a sudden overnight
you are now a field grade officer and
you're supposed to think strategically
and this transition point actually is a
big source of friction for a lot of
folks and the people that struggle the
most
going from company to field grade are
the ones who have never thought about
the big picture before
and it's not to say that as a second
lieutenant that i've been in the marine
corps for six months i need to walk into
the ceo's office and start
talking strategy but you have to start
thinking very early on about the impacts
of what you do to the big picture and
the sooner you can make the connection
the easier that transition is and the
longer you hold on it because it's kind
of like this
cool bravado of like i'm a tactician and
it sounds really cool
and i just want to fly the airplane and
i don't really care about the big
picture
well when the time comes you get
promoted and you probably will
it was really clear the ones who never
really thought about what they were
doing and how that fit in the larger
world when you made that promotion
then all of a sudden you actually became
highly incompetent at being a field
guide officer because that's when you
were starting
and you were being out maneuvered by
guys who had been doing it since they
were brand new officers
yeah you know what's really interesting
about that is
there are some people that have a
personality
and or skill set that is more suited to
be
a tactical officer and there's some
people that have a personality and skill
set that is more
suited to be a field-grade officer
or a strategic thinker that's and i see
this in companies too you know i've
worked with companies where
the ceo that got that company
from whatever position you know got them
to go public
or got them perched or poised to go
public
as soon as they're going public that
guy's out of there or maybe even before
they go public because this guy
he's good at making things happy dynamic
but he's not polished he's not clean he
can't brief up the chain of command well
he doesn't articulate himself
at the next level because some people
can flow from talking to a platoon
like listen up what's going on like you
you can be in that mode
and you can walk turn around and talk to
give the general a brief on what the
impact on the cultural moments or the
civilian populace and all those things
some people can do both some people do
one some people do the other
and it's very interesting it's very
interesting because
you might not make it to field grade
officer
even though you you might be you might
be good at it but you just don't have
the you just don't have it you know you
just don't have it
so think about that when you're working
with
you know when you got people
subordinates that you're working with
you might have somebody that's not
maybe the best tactical leader
are they can they do the job you know
what i mean
look they might not be able to do they
might not be the best at it but maybe
they can get through that job and they
can do a good job
as that at the next level up
and some people they might be incredible
at
getting after it in the field and you
can't let them brief
you can't let them brief the boss
because they're gonna mess it up
so so the good thing is if you're
if you're one of these humans out there
if you're one of these potential leaders
think about where you are and think
about modulating your personality
depending
i can promise you if you watched me
debrief a seal platoon
and then you watched me brief the
secretary of the navy
the those two guys like the venn diagram
overlap was pretty small if you were
just to take the words that i said just
a manuscript or whatever transcript of
what i said
the core things that i said the the i
wasn't saying anything different i
wasn't saying i wasn't
giving uh i wasn't lying to the big boss
and i wasn't lying to the troops
but the the method of delivery was
different
because of talking to a different
audience who understands things
differently
good thing to think about
a couple of these here trial by fire
trial by fire there's there's incredible
stories
inside these books um about what men
do and they're definitely worth look
this is another one from
we read one from this last time this is
from the uh the battle of the attu
island which is those aleutian islands
up in alaska
fighting the japanese this is a citation
the company led by captain thomas b
o'donnell was thrown into confusion by
the strafing of hostile airplanes while
it was forming to attack under heavy
enemy ground small arms fire
seeing the immediate need captain
o'donnell moved from his squad from
squad to squad restoring order and then
led his men to the assault
during which he received a severe wound
in the neck and shoulder and was
evacuated three days later upon hearing
that his company was again scheduled to
make an attack he insisted upon
returning to the fight although weak and
suffering severe pain from his wounds
he led his company in attacks on the
enemy until five days later when he was
mortally wounded
while moving about in advance positions
encouraging his men
one of the one of the um one of the
lessons that i taught
specifically i taught it to a bunch of
people but the first time i remember
teaching at someone was to uh was to
seth stone the delta platoon commander
who you know when you're doing immediate
action drills
there's there's standard operating
procedures and you follow
you follow those standard operating
procedures and he would
you know he would follow what the rules
were
and that if that meant that he was gonna
his next position that he was
supposed to go to according to the
standard operating procedures was behind
a berm
where he couldn't see anything that's
where he was going and you know i just
said hey man
why are you going there you know because
this is where we're supposed to go i
said can you see anything
no can you make a call no can you
can you lead your men no okay move move
around go see what you got to see
you can move around you could you don't
you don't you can't break the sops
there's a difference right you can't
break the sops but you don't have to
follow them
perfectly so there's a big difference
breaking the sops means you get out of
your lane and now you can get shot by
friendly fire
not following the sops means you're
staying within the confines of the rules
but you're still
moving around and telling people what to
do and you can imagine this is the
perfect example of what this whole thing
started off with which is look this guy
in order to get his troops to go
he had to personally get out there and
and
you know why would you risk your life
doing to in that's what it says
encourages men why would you risk your
life to encourage your men you know why
because if you don't do that your men
aren't going anywhere that's the
breaking the inertia you talked about at
the beginning exactly if you don't do
that as a leader you're gonna sit there
and you're gonna
you're gonna eventually you're gonna get
rolled you're all gonna die in that
position you cannot stay there
but the path of least resistance that
human nature is i like this box hole
yeah he's gonna hang out down here this
is good for me and he's like no
we can't stay here and leadership is the
only thing that gets people to see that
that that is those are the times when
you have to lead from the front you got
to make things happen
doubling in brass and i have no idea i
don't know if there's some weird
uh 1940s idiom that i don't know about
but this the titleist section is
doubling in brass citation
37th division new georgia while private
blair
f hertz was performing his duties with
the maintenance section in the vicinity
of the unit
ration dump they were attacked by japs
who had surrounded them
he grabbed a bar and advanced on a jap
machine gun that was delivering intense
accurate and extremely effective fire
into the dump private hertz was able to
silence this machine gun and then
continued to aid aggressively in the
defense of the position until
reinforcements arrived
just getting after it just in the rear
getting after it
when a citation starts with a private
you know you
know this is going to be a good one you
know he got some
yeah you know what's too bad is you know
in the navy you have rates
where you can tell what the guy's job
was this guy's just a private but you
know his job was probably
you know well he says mate his duties
with the maintenance section
so this guy was changing oils and
vehicles or something and then all of a
sudden
he's grabbing a bar and just getting
some
here we go dichotomy of leadership oh no
sorry this section isn't called that
it's called something else it's called
be brave intelligently
this is a weird one to read lieutenant
colonel ari o'brien
cavalry observer with the fifth army in
italy a prisoner of war
a german light machine gunner asked an
interrogator
whether americans took stimulants to
make them foolishly brave
when asked to explain what he meant he
stated that he and an assistant gunner
were in position with a good field of
fire one afternoon when a group of
american soldiers
was observed approaching he fired
several
short bursts and began preparation to
displace
to the rear when he saw the american
soldiers rise to full height
and start charging toward his position
over a hundred yards away
he reloaded his gun and opened fire
killing eleven men
he then withdrew because he was sure the
charge was made to conceal
an envelopment but none was made
unit commanders found it necessary to
direct their men to make full use of
concealment and covered
approach continued emphasis on the
necessity for dispersion
and the use of cover and concealment is
essential so
this is what we don't want to have
happen we don't want people to be so
brave
that you charge over an open area a
machine gun nest
and the comment here says in the
interest of efficiency
bravery must be supplemented by brain
work dead heroes are of little further
use to their units aggressive fighting
men
trained to apply the most efficient
technique to combat problems
willing to accept any necessary risks
and conscientiously avoiding
unnecessary risks are the backbone of
the army
got to be brave but you got to be smart
there's the dichotomy
what was the original uh the original
statement on that was brave but not
full hearty brave but not foolhardy
combat in towns as major campaigns
develop in western europe combat and
towns assumes increasing
importance cities towns and villages
control the established road nets which
must be open for the movement of guns
heavy equipment and supplies necessary
to support the advance of infantry
combat in towns will often be the key
not only to our
successful advanced but to successful
defensive actions
just talking about mount in 1944
attack of towns captain w.e harrison
harrison parachute infantry italy the
theory of attack of a small town or
village is to work
groups around the flanks cut the retreat
and move in with patrols
in this hilly country however we have
found that where there is any high
ground
behind the town which dominates both the
town and the line of retreat the best
way
is to work the entire force around the
town under cover
seize the high ground in the rear and
firmly establish ourselves with 60
millimeter mortars on that dominating
high ground
we take enough food and ammunition for
to last us 24 hours
and the germans usually pull out during
this time from our position we can
prevent reinforcement and inflict heavy
losses on them
during their withdrawal so we're
flanking people and we're taking high
ground
i didn't think of anything new
lieutenant colonel lg freeman parachute
infantry battalion
commander in italy we learned at
alta via to avoid the direct
attack of towns it's too costly we now
work around to the rear with a large
force and seize the dominating ground in
the rear we did this at kallo
machia fornelli and several other places
the names of which i've forgotten i like
it when you're just forgetting major
battles that you've had
it worked every time get yourself within
60 millimeter mortar range of the town
on dominating terrain
in or near it and the germans won't stay
in it
and then it says this here's the comment
i like these comments
the fact that the germans had been known
to withdraw without a fight from towns
in the rear
of which we hold dominating terrain does
not necessarily mean that such will
invariably be the rule however this
possibility plus the fact the caesar of
such
high ground will greatly facilitate any
subsequent attack
on the town proper suggests that
commanders should give
serious consideration to these tactics
where the terrain permits it also should
be remembered that if such high ground
is held
by the enemy our attack on the town
proper will invariably be costly
and the town itself untenable that's how
important high ground is
in planning the attack of a town proper
the following considerations
should be borne in mind one reduced
observation and limited fields of fire
in place
of heavier stress on close combat so you
are going to get some
to controlling of attacking troops will
be difficult
and much depends on individual
initiative
and aggressiveness of small unit leaders
so there you go we
we we opened up talking about how you
better follow all these orders
and now we're on page eight and we're
talking about
hey you know what it depends on the
initiative
of initiative and aggressiveness of
small unit leaders
making things happen
where possible towns should be bypassed
isolated and attacked from the flanks or
the rear
why are we even attacking this position
if we don't have to
roll around it imagine if you made that
part of your everyday
sort of scheme of maneuver i can beat my
head against this wall or i can walk
around it
it seems like a good idea
at least it seems like a good idea to me
i don't know echo's over there shaking
his head
a lot of times when you say every you
know you use those what do you call
those words that are real like
real permanent yeah like do that in
everything
you know every time you say that i think
i just triggered id
i took some i took some heat off of it
by saying it seems like
yeah that would be a good thing to do
and part of your everyday plan
yeah yeah then that's what kind of
triggered me
though to think like of all the things
that it probably
or maybe wouldn't work yeah i don't know
would you treat your workouts like that
let me sidestep this workout maybe flank
it
you're on dangerous ground right now
yes sir you're going at it you're
potentially right about that one
i'm just saying usually when it comes to
workouts i'm to smash the workout
let's face it you know i'm going to go
ahead and full frontal assault yes sir
well i i would think so
anyway unless i may guess it depends on
what you mean by flank
like i guess you could flank your
initial feelings
about the incoming workout if you don't
feel like doing it
you know you could maybe maneuver that
way maybe
but maybe maybe not i don't know maybe
just direct assault work out
smash it get it done i like it there are
times
there are times so maybe not everything
in life you know
maybe not everything yeah but maybe if
you're dealing with other people
it's a good call yeah that could be the
case
uh this section here starts talking
about like how you actually
clear towns and it goes through and then
it gets to a point where it starts just
telling the comments about the story so
i'm not going to dump into the story i'm
not going to go deep into the story here
but just some of the comments here about
the defense of a town the defense of a
town must be prepared to meet the
methods of attack which may be employed
by the enemy
since this must include the possibility
of flanking attacks and encirclement it
follows
that an all-around defense must be the
rule
the following points not covered in the
experience quoted above which is the one
that i didn't read which is why you
should read these things yourself
should be born in mind in planning the
defense of a town
one avoid if possible placing principal
centers of resistance
close to landmarks or at the edge of a
town where the enemy adjustment of
artillery or mortar fire
will be facilitated positions either
outside
or within the town should be chosen
and i read this whole section to read
this
and it's something that we talked about
the other day on ef online and i don't
know you were if you
were on the call and i talked about
don't give away your position yes yeah
totally
i went into a whole a whole
explanation of not giving away your
position
and it's weird it's a weird thing to
talk about because it seems real sneaky
yeah right it seems real like oh
it seems real sneaky especially when
people love so much to talk about like
being transparent but here's the deal
if you have an idea dave and i have my
own idea
if i just put my stake in the ground and
say my idea is this
i'm giving away my position now if we
were going to go attack
an enemy outpost i would do everything i
possibly could to avoid giving away
my position because once i give away my
position well now you know
where to attack me on so what i would
rather do
is listen to what you have to say here
let let me understand what your position
is
because then it allows me to maneuver
and change my position and also
if you're an offensive person and your
ego's out of control
as soon as you see my position get guess
what you're going to do attack it
so i gave you my position now you're
going to attack it now what do i do then
dig in now what do we have a standoff we
have
extra casualties we don't need so why am
i giving away my position
when i'm having a conversation and this
is it's one of those things
it sounds so manipulative right
but then i took it a little bit further
on the ef online i
said this is the facts the reason i
don't give away my position
is because i don't actually have one
i'm not rolling in there thinking that i
know
everything i'm thinking i may have some
ideas that could you might be able to
calculate
and estimate approximate where i am but
i'm not going to go in there and say
dave i believe this
because not just because i want to hide
it from you that's not why
it's because i actually question my own
beliefs
i actually am not looking at you
thinking i
know the best thing to do i've got some
ideas but
you can't lock down my position because
i'm not gonna stay there i'm not digging
in
being transparent this authenticity
doesn't have to be in opposition to what
we just described either
being transparent could be hey i'm going
to
i'm going to have a conversation with
tell you a whole bunch of things that
i'm thinking about
that are things for you to consider as
well for me maybe thinking
what i don't want to do is sit here and
go hey you've mentioned three things
that i really feel like i want to give
you feedback on
but i don't want to tell you those
things for whatever reason
being transparent is not the same as
digging your heels in
those the authenticity of that there's
this you would know this echo
there's this social media thing where
like somebody says some statement
it's like a meme and then it says prove
me wrong it'll say like
martians colonize the moon prove me
wrong or
louder with crowd or situation whatever
i don't i i i should know more about it
i know that you probably know enough but
there's this little
what kind of underneath that is this
idea like
you're not going to change my mind i
know that you are not going to change my
mind
i'm being fully transparent here this
idea of transparency
doesn't have to be the opposite of
what you just described you can be fully
transparent and if i actually my
relationship is strong enough with you
you know what you're going to do when
i'm being transparent you're going to
listen to me
and then you're going to come back with
some things oh that's a good point and
then actually together what will happen
is we'll come up with the right plan and
then we'll go execute it and it'll be
awesome
yeah the idea of not giving away your
position you don't give it away not
because you did
not cause you're hiding it it's because
you're truly don't don't know you don't
lock yourself
into it yeah so i'm not walking into
conversations i know i know what to do
i'm not doing that and if you if you're
in a leadership
role if you're in an actual leadership
role how much do you think
your people really want to engage with
you if you announce your position out of
the gate
like what's the chances of them giving
you great feedback being transparent
yeah
yeah how does that encourage
transparency from the troops
answer it doesn't well and if it does
hey dave that sounds like a great idea i
fully support your idea you're so smart
yeah which is the last thing you want as
a leader to be told how smart you are by
your subordinates you want to be told
hey i don't agree with you oh great tell
me why
where practicable form salience by
organizing outlying buildings to cover
perimeter
of town with flanking and unfilled fire
i had to look up the word salience
because i didn't know what it meant
it's like a little projection that's
sticking out of the battle line
so you in order to get a little better
cover you can you can take an outlying
building and you can set up a kind of a
fort there
the noun a salient yeah form salience
because there's a word salient right
yeah it means like significant or
what does that mean i think it's like a
clear point yeah which is the
the other it's the same thing right a
clear point
well here i am making this it's like a
projection it's a point something that
sticks out but
that was a salient point yeah meaning oh
yeah that was a good point i understand
what you said
oh we built a salient out there oh it's
a little point where we've got the solid
coverage
kind of like monolithic kind of the same
deal
yeah i guess kind of kind of the same
deal like there's a there's a
monolith which is the noun version of
monolithic
kind of kind of thing yes there are
all kinds of words that are based on
other words hey i'm just trying to
understand this whole deal
every once in a while echo says
something and then once he says that he
writes down a little note and that means
he's going to go back and edit himself
out
i don't know if that made the list i
think he's going to hold it i think he's
going strong
no hey may that'll probably help some
people as far as
as far as salient in salience goes yeah
and
and also help people realizing that
there are multiple versions of the same
words
in the world yes it's true
i'm a jerk
in addition to a central reserve within
the town provide if possible
for a concealed mobile reserve
preferably strong in armor
to be held outside the town to counter
enemy flanking maneuver and once again
what is the root of that right there
don't give away your position the root
of it is hey hide
this element which is smart
keep it mobile wherever adjacent terrain
features dominate the town
they should be secured obviously this
use of high ground
may be key to successful defense that's
funny they say dominant terrain and then
they just call it high ground
within the town the construction of
street obstacles or barricades to impede
enemy movements and the organization of
groups
of buildings into strong points should
be carried out as extensively as
time available will permit
strengthen your defenses in delaying
actions the defensive use of towns will
prevent the attacker from determining
the strength
of the opposing of the forces opposing
him it is not
normally advisable to organize a town as
an isolated strong point
except under terrain conditions which
prevent the enemy
bypassing it so don't stick a town out
there on its own
don't stick anyone out there on their
own unless the terrain allows it
so then there's a um
i didn't cover one of these one of these
sections but
this one when i started reading it and
as i read through it i said to myself
this is such a great example of
simplicity
and the way this this battalion attack
happens
and then the way it gets debriefed is
all very interesting so i'm going to
burn through this real quick
mission this is a battalion attack in
italy mission lieutenant colonel
earl taylor infantry battalion commander
in italy on october
on 11 october my battalion was ordered
to make a night march
pass through the second battalion which
was about three miles
east of the italian town of guardia
north of the calor river and seized the
high ground
in the vicinity of guardia we were then
to continue the advance
contact as we approached guardia our
leading company made contact with the
enemy
at a and there's a sketch that they go
through this it enveloped with one
platoon go stop by heavy machine gun and
direct 88 millimeter fire from points e
f and d
and was unable to advance i immediately
moved to the high ground so
basically they get into a big gunfight
and they can't
they can't move forward and here's
here's what i like i immediately
moved to the high ground 200 yards north
where i could observe the enemy position
so
right now we have observed happening
getting on the high ground love that
observe what's he doing why is he
observing well because he's got to
figure out what to do
now he gets up in this observation
position
and he says the enemy had all of the
high ground to the front and i could see
it would be impossible to advance
frontally
so what does that mean now he's
orienting himself to the situation oh
the enemy's got all this high ground up
here
i can't advance friendly so that was he
to do so
i decided to make
a double development sending company i
over the hill to the right and company k
on a wide left envelopment
contact was to be maintained visually so
that there's the action
it's actually happening so he goes
through the oota loop in like four
sentences which is totally legit yeah
base of fire five tanks were available
for the attack realizing that the tanks
could not
move down the road to guardia which is
the only tank approach
due to the streams and high mountains
and because the enemy had 88s and
armored cars at f i decided to in place
the tanks along with my eight heavy
machine guns
and six 81 millimeter mortars as shown
in the sketch
results the attack was successful
by order the tanks and other supporting
weapons open
fire five minutes before company l
started its advance that is called cover
and move
we got tanks and and supporting weapons
firing
and then company else starts their move
after five minutes 15 prisoners were
captured 25 enemy killed our casualties
were approximately 10 killed
and 15 wounded which when you think
about the
assault on a you know in an urban
environment you're going to take some
casualties and those are certain
certainly some casualties but those are
not as bad as you might imagine going
into a city when you consider the fact
that if you don't know anything about
urban combat
one enemy with a machine gun
can kill dozens and dozens of troops
the enemy strength as determined from
prisoners was two rifle companies each
reinforced
supported by tanks armored cars and 88s
along the road
these prisoners stated that their force
was so completely disorganized and
demoralized by our volume of fire that
and scheme of attack
that was impossible for them to make a
counter attack and regain their
positions
planning it took about two hours to make
plans for this attack
which was very carefully studied planned
and coordinated it's funny
sometimes the us military spends months
making plans for an attack and and
he's saying this took two hours but it
was carefully studied planned and
coordinated that's what he needed was a
solid two hours
it effectively utilized the terrain
features every weapon available to the
battalion was used in such an attack
maps must be pre-arranged with critical
points and phase lines
once the attack is started the basic
plan cannot be changed
it must succeed that's an interesting
statement and i the
the word that i underlined was basic
you're not in your head dave like yeah
my immediate reaction is must not be
changed i get
like an intense like oh but yeah you're
right the basic plan
it doesn't say we can't change so rather
than sort of get all excited that he
says he can't change anything is to
he's right yeah especially at night and
when you look at this whole situation
you actually want to limit the amount of
replanting and recoil
you want to limit a lot of things now
not the individual actions of the teams
of maneuvering and things like that and
let them make the adjustments
but you don't want one element to go you
know what let's cancel the envelopment
and just do something different and
abandon your portion of the plane
you actually can't do that so you
actually need to keep the basic plan
that that clarity actually made a lot of
sense yeah that one word
yeah that one word makes a big
difference when you start thinking about
what they're doing you've got
what is it eight heavy machine guns
since those guys are doing
a fire a fire mission on this town for
five minutes before you enter the town
that's coordination you can't start
thinking well you know i think i'm gonna
go early or whatever it is you're
the basic plan you got to stick with
that basic plan
then i i this is something that i lived
by
if i if it was possible to stick with
the basic plan
i was sticking with the basic plan like
it would have to be something really now
we would have a contingency plan
hey but if i could avoid using the
contingency plan
i i would stick with the basic plan that
we we that we rehearsed and we would
rehearse the contingency too but yeah
people expect what they're going to be
doing we had the exact same philosophy
we we had contingency plans but the part
of that that made that possible is our
plans were usually really fluid
some key limits you had some limiting
decisions inside there
but our plans weren't hyper detailed and
super down to the
so you could stick to the basic plan we
used to have just a joke stick to the
plan that was what we always said like
what do you do here just stick to the
plan
that didn't mean you don't think you
don't make changes but the idea that
what we planned and how we coordinated
stick to that
and then make smart decisions along the
way to reinforce that as opposed to you
get halfway there and then
hey you know what we should do we should
come up with a new plan like there's no
time to come up with a new plan once you
cross the line of departure you kind of
need to stick to the plan
the basic plan which also drove our
plans to be
basic we had very basic big picture
plans yeah
simple and flexible if you know
if the three of us were gonna go and
take down a building
and we say okay here's the way it's
gonna go once we get to the front door
echo you're gonna open the door
dave you're gonna go left i'm gonna go
right and then
echo you're gonna go left and we go okay
and we rehearse that 10 times
i promise you that as we approach that
building there's going to be a
civilian in the front yard that echoes
going to have to deal with and all of a
sudden that whole plan's out the window
so you can't go to that level of detail
and you definitely
need to have flexibility there but the
basic plan of hey we're going to
approach the building
totally that's not going to change
because we know where the fire support
is etc etc etc
estimating the situation and planning
should be emphasized in training comment
and this was
i found this interesting too
this account is a good example of fire
and movement
on the battalion though i have no idea i
guess i guess i got it from roger hayden
why
why i use the term cover and move
instead of fire movement because of the
same thing
but i same thing cover and move and fire
movement are the same thing
this account at least as far as i know
does am i am i missing something
i don't think so we used the term fire
and maneuver yeah that was
the one element moves one element covers
and i think it's synonymous
yeah yeah however it should be pointed
out that a double envelopment is a
rather ambitious schema maneuver for a
single battalion and should be used with
caution and i
loved seeing that because
what you're talking about echo charles
is you're you're talking about a double
involvement you're basically surrounding
a target
which means you got
good guys on the flanks of bad guys
and if you start shooting at the bad
guys in the middle you can shoot
yourself
and it's really problematic the the
thing about this and there would be
occasional
seal platoons that would go yeah we're
gonna we're gonna just surround the
target
it works when nothing goes wrong it
works when the enemy doesn't start
shooting
it works if you have on the positive
side it works if you have a terrain
feature that prevents
friendly fire which is possible you can
have a you know a ravine that allows you
to be in a certain position
but when you
when you do these battalion sized
operations you're actually getting out
of the you should be moving outside the
range of your own weapons which is what
the goal is right you know we're really
far away
and and as long as we are shooting our
weapons at the enemy
there's a very small chance that our
weapons are going to hit
our friendly forces so
be very careful about double envelopment
and same thing with going to uh enemies
rear like if you're going to do that
well then you've got to pay attention to
how that's going to work out it is a lot
harder than it looks
no mention is made of the constitution
of a reserve force
such a reserve must be retained under
the control of the commander to enable
to counter unforeseen enemy reaction as
the attack progresses
troops committed to a plan of action
cannot be considered as available
for this purpose the division
of the battalion into into approximately
three
equal attack forces is open to criticism
but it worked in this case
a schema maneuver should include a
determina determination of the direction
of the main effort
and the preponderance of the force
should be available to support this
effort here's an interesting
story so one of the great tactical
lessons learned of my life which i
learned in training
when you so we would set up you know to
to do target assaults typical is any
army manual any
any marine corps manual how you do a
target assault you know you set up a
base
element and a maneuver element so the
base element is gonna engage the target
it gets in position and it shoots at the
target once it's shot at the target for
a certain amount of time the assault
element then gets up
and maneuvers towards the target when
they get to a certain point
the people shooting at the target shift
fire off the target but they keep
shooting
and eventually they move the assault
team moves through the target
and i was watching
a young junior officer i was in training
at seal team one
and he he said okay what we're gonna do
is for our base element that's gonna do
all the shooting at the target area
what we're gonna do is we're going to
take our machine gunners from
the other from the assault element who
has to move
we're going to move the machine gunners
into the base arm we're going to take
some of the riflemen and put them in the
assault element so they can move easier
they can get through the target
and i said i was thinking to myself
that's pretty smart smart guy is going
to get a really strong base element
vietnam vet said what are you doing
he said well you know you know master
chief i'm going to go ahead and put
heavier stronger bass over here and the
machine got a helmet and i put all my
machine guns over in the base element
and i'm like i can already tell i'm glad
i wasn't coming up with this plan
but why is that you know he says well
because i want to have more machine guns
i want to have more firepower in my base
element
and then the the master chief in one
question
said what happens if the assault element
gets compromised
on the way in
end of discussion because now we don't
have any machine guns
and and by the way what should happen is
if we have machine guns in the assault
element
the assault element just became the base
element that's what just happened
so and and the thing that the other
lesson that i learned from that
was that what you really get to do the
other
benefit which i actually would say is an
even bigger benefit
is we have unit integrity which i love
unit integrity that squad or that
platoon is always working together
the machine gunners are there they can
break off they can assault things they
can do they can do all kinds of things
where when you pull those machine
gunners out they're not
they're way less capable
so apply that to your business to your
team how do we keep the teams together
how do we keep the teams together how do
we keep them both
how do we keep them most capable that's
what we want to do
setting up little specialty moments
is a risky call factors contributing to
the success in this attack were
prompt estimate of the situation by the
commander including a study of the
terrain
based on personal reconnaissance
development of a definite plan of
maneuver based on the seizure
terrain and outflanking enemy positions
detailed planning of specific orders
utilization of maximum firepower where
available
maintenance of control over the elements
a little section here on fighting in
wooded terrain lieutenant colonel
f l walker infantry battalion commander
italy the area in which my battalion
operated was covered in thick scrub
trees and fruit orchards
interspersed with frequent farmhouses
many stone walls six to eight feet in
height
and numerous sunken roads field of fire
was greatly restricted
average observation was only 50 to 100
yards
enemy delaying groups with machine guns
were widely scattered
and impossible to locate until arrival
within a hundred yards or less
it was found necessary to place heavy
weapons out in the front line or very
close up
to avoid hitting our troops after
encountering hostile fire it was found
very effective to spray the entire woods
ahead with a massive concentration of
mortar and machine gun fire
for about one minute followed by a rapid
advance of rifle platoons
under assault fire to cover all the
trees and house windows
where snipers might be hiding in each
case germans pulled out rapidly leaving
weapons and ammunition behind
although we had been unable to locate
them previously however the tendency
of troops is to wait for definitely
located targets before they will open
fire
which results in allowing very small
groups of enemy
to shift position frequently and keep up
a demoralizing rate of machine gun fire
to cause a great delay
the continuous rapid fire delivered by
our heavy machine guns
had a particularly demoralizing effect
on the germans
the remarks of this battalion commander
emphasized the importance of barrage
covering fire the fire power of
available weapons in this instance
substituted for an artillery barrage
but the principle remains the same
covered move
losses will be minimized by following
closely the massed fires of available
weapons delivered in areas
from which enemy fire is expected
i think the enemy might be there i'm
putting rounds into it
and isn't it interesting how that one
dynamic think about that learn that
lesson learned
of realizing hey what we need to do
is lay down heavy fire wherever we think
there might be enemy and push forward as
quickly as we can
think about that lesson like think about
the first time it happens the first time
it happens like oh where are they where
are they no one's shooting
and then someone goes hey put down fire
and advance
and guys start laying down fire and they
start laying down fire where they think
there's enemy
and then that allows you to get the
enemies heads down because they are
somewhere out there
and you get their heads down and now
you're maneuvering and when you're
maneuvering they're not
and now you win but can you imagine that
that's a little bit off of our instinct
right as a human if you don't
if you don't if you don't get trained
that way your instinct is not
hey i'm just gonna shoot where i think
there's bad guys i'm gonna shoot in that
little dark corner over there i'm gonna
shoot in that
window over there i'm gonna shoot near
that stone wall over there you haven't
seen one enemy but that's where you're
shooting
and now you have a whole company of
soldiers doing that that's a lot of
firepower going downrange and it allows
you to move
because somewhere in one of those
positions there was enemy
but think about what it took to learn
that lesson and how valuable that lesson
right there is to be able to tell people
and it also talks about the importance
of speed which is the next
note regimental commander infantry
sicily
i believe that the individual soldier
now realizes that a relentless steady
advance
saves casualties and that he is now
imbued with the knowledge of the
importance of speed
every man in this regiment is firmly
convinced that the speed of our recent
operations
saved us from huge losses down to the
lowest private
the feeling exists that we would still
be at
kanasady if we had not
pushed the enemy off balance and kept
him that way
you know how often are we sitting there
waiting for
the perfect plan the perfect whatever
when what we should be doing is moving
right you you want to just bring this
down to working out echo charles since
that seems to be your main
you know topic for the day all right
yeah cool
yes so let's look at two options one
all right what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
go and research on the internet you know
what the max
time under load i need to do for this
particular workout right
time under tension right but come up
with
my periodic periodicity periodization
my periodization for my workouts right
all these things that you could spend
two hours
researching and then writing and mapping
out or you could go do a bunch of
cleaning jerks
just go yeah there is an advantage to
doing cleaning jerks
look i'm not saying you got to be an
idiot no
no but there are some some positive
things to just
going yes and keeping moving and firing
where you
think it might hey i don't know about
the
the the the um
the internal bicep head or whatever the
brachial head of the bicep which i know
you probably got some
little high tuned exercises in short
hands yeah there you go so you do
certain types of curls with the easy bar
to
hit that target right yeah whereas you
could just say hey let's face it
go do some curls right yeah yeah
actually you're right i actually agree
with you hundred percent i agree with
that philosophy
in working out yeah i mean there's a
couple of things you want to know
otherwise you're just kind of
you know moving around with with no
specific direction which i
you know teach their own but yeah i
i think that actually is a very good
analogy you know you see you sort out
what am i trying to do here um get a few
basic
methods on try to you know how to
achieve it and just go
especially when you start coupling that
attitude with the fact that
we don't want to move in the first place
right that inertia is we're just trying
to stay still
and now we can we can we can focus on
that by just doing a bunch of planning
like hey i'm just waiting to see where
the bad guys are i'm just waiting
no freaking lay down fire that's that's
the way you wake up in the morning you
wake up in the morning saying i'm gonna
put down
fire yeah that's what i'm gonna do
that's a good plan
yeah very good plan yeah you're right
about that too how you you're like oh
wait
what wait let me try to remember what i
was gonna do today and be like well i
should maybe i should do this because
tomorrow
i'm gonna do this so maybe i shouldn't
do this you know i shouldn't do it that
hard
or in you know and you spend all this
time and then it's like well shoot if i
do the whole workout now shoot dinners
like in like
45 minutes so maybe i should i don't
know i'm just saying
depends on when you work out i guess
sure you know not in your case for sure
maybe a breakfast or whatever but yeah
then you're like oh that's 45 minutes
that only gives me like 10 minutes to
like or one minute to warm up and maybe
man i might as well just do this
tomorrow that way i can get the whole
thing done you see what i'm saying
and yeah bro that planning not only did
it not a lot of that
not matter meanwhile weakness is winning
in your body
meanwhile weakness is winning man and
then there's that to avoid
yeah is that i think it was you who
talked about i don't know
whatever but yeah when you let the
weakness creep in you give that weakness
a precedent
you know so the pres the weakness is
sort of like oh yeah i kind of
approved my my my presence kind of thing
i was talking about this on ef online
the other day i i i've been doing this
lately in my head
so and i haven't quite figured out what
this means but i know it's been
very functional
when you have like uh an option
of doing a bad thing or
just not doing the bad thing
that reaction of just not doing the bad
thing isn't strong enough
i've actually been trying to do
something good
okay does that make sense i think let me
explain again so example
oh there's a donut over there you know
what i'm not going to eat the donut
that's not strong enough not only am i
not going to eat the doughnut
i'm actually going to go and do 20
burpees
yeah and you know it doesn't even have
to be extreme because guess what you
you're we're working or whatever and
just like i just want to have a no no
i'm not going to eat that doughnut and
you know what i'm going to do i'm going
to go and
uh get my desk cleared off right now
yeah kind of on top
doing something actually proactive right
to crush
yeah to crush that weakness weakness
that's wanting to grow it's just it's
like if
it's like you know if i says hey echo uh
heck oh you know you you wanna you wanna
come by my house and
and and grill up some steaks and let's
say you don't really feel like doing it
and so you're like well you know what i
mean i'm gonna pressure you
but if you're like negative i'm already
doing something i'm like okay that case
closed right
case closed you already won yeah so i'm
just saying going a little bit harder at
the weakness
yeah there's a little trend i'm in right
now yeah and that and that
works i mean it depends on what you mean
by works but that's a good move that's
like yeah you know like yeah i'm about
to um
like okay i have i have burpees at the
end of this workout i finished the work
a workout with 100 burpees we'll say
i'll be like man
that workout was pretty solid you know i
don't know about those burpees you know
let's let's we'll do those burpees
another time we're going to skip the
burpees this is what we're going to do
then it comes time to skip the property
like you know what no 150
or 200 now yeah just for thinking that
you know
oh yeah you're going hard on weakness
yes i think that's a positive thing i
think you're right
i'm gonna start like this this ties in
for me i'm gonna start laying down
fire if i now i'm gonna start being even
more proactive i start seeing weakness
i'm laying down fire i'm putting
i'm putting some mortar rounds on that
stuff immediately
would you write down dave i think we
went so far away from whatever i'm not
sure i can bring us back
we're talking about burpees and bicep
curls bro
you talked about bias before so actually
there might be a little connection here
if we think about it for a second you
were talking about
well you actually weren't talking about
bias i had the word bias in my mind
um when we had a plan hey we're gonna go
in the building you're gonna go to the
the east stairwell you're gonna go to
the west
and hey we that might not happen we
might have to do something different we
used to briefly get on missions these
these general missions
like hey all things being equal i want
you to buy us to the south
and if you know we get additional
pressure you're gonna be the
element that biases to the south now
look something may come up where you
can't do that and that's fine you may go
to the north
go and let me know but our plan is that
all things being equal
we're gonna bias in this direction which
allows me to keep my plans like
really general yeah that's about as
general as it gets yeah but it's great
and it's but it's it's not completely
like out in nowhere where you don't have
some idea but it's like hey these are
the things we're anticipating and all
things being equal i want
you were you were we were talking about
the um
the inertia thing which has kind of
bugged me from the beginning but i
actually was thinking about as you were
saying it is
you know he's talking about like the
laws of physics whereas
objects and at rest tend to stay at rest
and objects in motion tend to stay
in motion and the hard part is getting
the the staying at rest and getting it
to the motion like once you get the
motion going actually it's not that hard
to keep it going
it's the friction of doing nothing and
it's that connection you you like you
said i know you didn't invent it but
this idea of default aggressive this
bias for doing something is the hardest
thing to get
which is the natural bias
of doing something and when you made
that comment about when i see
weakness or i feel weakness the natural
bias is
oh no i'm not going to give in to that
weakness i'm going to do nothing which
everybody's like that's the win and
you're like no actually that's not the
win
the win is not to do nothing
is it better than eating a donut yes but
we're not here to just not eat donuts
that's not the game we're playing over
here
the game we're playing is just not to
eat the donuts
and he started the very first thing is
leadership versus
inertia it's that how hard is it to get
the movement to do something but once
you have that
bias that bias to maneuver
and that starts it's not that hard it
actually gets easier
every single time so that's my
connection to things you were saying and
yeah
i'm going to let you guys talk about
what it is you talk about but that's
what i was thinking about is that what
that bias really means
to tie back to the very first thing that
i kind of thought about was like hey
what's he talking about because i was
thinking inertia is movement
inertia is not movement it's just the
state that you're in inertia could be
doing nothing
and that's what he's talking about
breaking out of that and the bias to
move
uh which is the the most challenging
thing yeah i talk about pushing a train
you know and i was like hey if you're
gonna push a train
the first getting that thing to start
moving is the hardest part
and you start pushing you push you push
and it
eventually starts to move a little bit
and then you get to a point
if you keep pushing that thing where you
can actually like
grab onto the railing and hang on for a
second it's just gonna keep going
you started it when you were talking
about blasting a rocket ship out of here
exactly
you can actually use 90 of your effort
to get that and you'll need you don't
need 90 you can coast
the rest of the way once you break free
of that gravitational force
of like literally i'm just gonna i don't
i'm just on the train now yeah
now look if you can just jump on a
speeding train go for it but most of us
most people have to actually get that
train from a dead stop and move it yeah
you ever see those guys uh roll up a
frying pan
like a like a piece of paper kind of
thing i think that's
like the the method really yeah like you
hit it like real hard at that initial
and then it like heats up the molecule
so it becomes more
yeah i'm not mistaken unless i got
tricked or something like that and it's
a one big trick but
i'm pretty sure that
you're seeming to bring it to some sort
of molecular level which i'm not sure
about that was the explanation
for real they're like this is the trick
this is how you do it you know what i
do not know if you're right and i do not
know if you are wrong
i'm gonna just leave it hanging and
people will let us know and we will get
someone with a frying pan
posting it and telling us hey echo
charles is 100
right or echo charles
the most likely outcome of this is
neither of those it's
bro echo talking about frying pans when
we're talking about combat
that's the most likely these concepts
are everywhere there's only so much i
can do
to keep us on topic here echo i'm just
saying if you can work with a frying pan
bruh it's good and rocket ships and
whatnot it can work with like
everyday stuff and i actually think echo
is the premier example in the world
premier example of in the world in the
entire world of
if you know the way broadly you see it
in all things you're seeing combat in a
frying pan
these ideas are everywhere for sure but
there was uh the
as far as feats of strength go there's
the ripping the phone book one yeah
right
i think there's a little trick because
you gotta like unbunch them or bunch up
but
your point is that that initial the
initial break is the hard part that's
hard most of your energy
so that's where you use technique well
well okay how it went was
the cur the rolling up of the frying pan
how how it's explained is
you hit it with that first force of the
rolling action
but you just can't like you can't hit
one and then re-grip
and hit another one it's not like that
you gotta hit it once and just keep keep
going
don't let like the momentum stop
because the molecules are still heated
up for that moment
it makes it more malleable or whatever
that's how it was explained to me
all right we're going to look up you're
going out on the limb i like it dude you
got no problem taking risk
i like the way you roll next one the
herd instinct major
robert wilson observer with the x
division they don't name the division in
italy
our troops echo's taking a note maybe
he's concerned that's getting edited
oh you're going strong today our troops
showed a decided tendency to bunch up
under fire
this was observed on several occasions
one prisoner wore a german forward
observer
for an 88 millimeter battery was
interrogated concerning his technique of
adjustment
it seems he had been told that american
troops congregated went under fire
when he saw american troops advancing he
would call for one or two rounds in
their vicinity and observe
the area where they congregated fire was
then
shifted to that area the prisoner stated
that he conducted very effective fire in
this way in several occasions on
italy don't bunch up not good don't
bunch up
leadership strategy and tactics talk
about this from my leadership
perspective
let the leader lead you don't need to
jump in there and crowd the leader
everyone's like getting there
let me tell you my opinion it's like
listen to what the moss has to say if
you want some suggestions give it to
them
don't crowd don't bunch up base of fire
lieutenant colonel jm
fan infantry battalion commander it was
found
that so long as japs could keep us
ducking from
aimed fire their position remained
secure
but once the jap was made to keep his
head down and the americans could get to
his feet and attack
it was merely a matter of walking up to
the position and tossing in grenades
to make this possible require the
coordination of fires down to and
including the riflemen
it is important that commanders and
leaders realize this otherwise troops
will remain down when it is not
necessary
it's so amazing it's so amazing
cover move teamwork down to the lowest
level yeah and i just said teamwork and
guess what the next section's called and
i i did not look at this next section of
teamwork
we would have a rifleman point out a
pillbox using tracer ammunition then a
37 millimeter gun would take them under
fire with high explosives
oftentimes a pillbox crew would attempt
to evacuate to a safer place and the
light machine gun would mow them down
it interesting when we talk about
teamwork and we talk about cover move
the reason that it is such an incredible
metaphor is because if you don't
cover and move you don't win it's as
simple as that if you don't have one
element that's shooting at the japanese
while the other element is walking up
and if you don't do that you lose
that's what happens you lose if you do
that you win
if you work together as a team you win
here's lieutenant colonel tf bogart
infantry officer
italy one night in the vicinity of
the battalion established an outpost
line around the high ground to the
northeast the city patrols were ordered
up several roads leading out of the city
all company commanders were informed of
the dispositions
the patrols went out before the outposts
were posted
a few hours later firing was heard at
the battalion cp which increased in
tempo
and kept up most of the night soon
reports were sent
that sent in that german patrols were
operating in front of the outposts
i'm sure you all know what's coming next
morning it became apparent that our own
patrols
had been fired on as they attempted to
return to the outpost line
comment the constant recurrence of such
reports indicates the necessity for
closer coordination of patrol activity
with the outpost of with the outpost
system positive steps
must be taken to ensure that the routes
of returning patrols are known to the
outposts and that recognition signals
are arranged
blue on blue no one thinks it's gonna
happen
no one thinks it's gonna happen
i never never even thought about blue on
blues it was like such a
it seemed like such a i i shouldn't say
we never thought about them but it
seemed like such a
foreign idea you'd think how could that
ever happen
the way i no one ever thinks it's going
to happen to them well that's true
they always know what happens but it
always happens to
somebody else some other team someone it
never happens to them
i mean that comment is like the common
occurrence or the common debrief that we
got on this thing whatever he said like
how often they heard that same exact
story
notes from other arms there's another
one about just staying off the skyline
right don't give away your position
i just had to highlight this there was a
section about what it was like when they
had an anti-aircraft
versus when they didn't have it and then
the title of this section is
absence makes the heart grow fonder
and what it was like and and that what
he says in here
is that the rarely would the
anti-aircraft
actually hit a german aircraft that was
strafing him it would rarely happen
but when the anti-aircraft wasn't there
the german
aircraft would just come down and just
hammer free reign
radio discipline first lieutenant ce
plays
air corps sicily flyers coming into the
combat zone
had no conception of radio discipline
dave
new pilots use the radio
indiscriminately men returning from
missions used the
interplane radio unnecessarily which
jammed up the band for
other planes still on a mission comma
failure to observe radio discipline is a
major problem for both air and ground
units
in combat each individual believes his
case is a special one
not bound by established rules this
tendency must
be discouraged by positive action radio
discipline is established to facilitate
essential communications during combat
and is not a peacetime play thing to be
discarded when action is joined
and this is this is task unit bruiser
we were freaking awesome at radio
discipline
we did not talk on the radio in fact
there would be
operations where some some task units
might use
two or even three separate radio nets to
coordinate
and in task unit bruiser we would use
one
and it would be almost completely silent
so yeah and how does this translate into
regular life it's
talking all the time it's not having
discipline what the hell you say
just feeling like you gotta throw in
your two cents all the time
and yes for those of you that aren't
seeing this on youtube
i'm looking right right at my friend
echo charles
whatever african um you know when i talk
i think anyway i don't know i i could be
wrong here
maybe i'm trying to just support the
point you know bring it down to the
everyday level
right off see i'm saying i think there's
a you have a lot of supporters out there
at least
enough yeah the radio discipline thing
isn't it weird too this this idea that
everyone
in combat each individual believes his
case is a
special one that's such a derogatory
statement
and and you know what's funny about that
derogatory statement
everyone that hears it thinks they're
talking about someone else like that's
not
me but it is you you are
talking and no one wants to hear you and
what you have to say
isn't that important is that kind of
like talking about your dreams
with your friends no idea you ever like
to you ever get your friend but i guess
i'm about to have an idea no if i could
you know when your friend is like hey i
had this dream last night and it was
about and and it's not about you or
nothing but it's like this is just the
weirdest dream
aren't you like bro who cares you know
but if you ever find yourself telling
whoever about your dreams
yeah it seems like it's so interesting
it was just so bizarre and all this
stuff
you know the person was like bruh be
quiet
you know radio silence resounding
metaphor complete
captured documents big section about um
upon searching the bodies they found a
map of the second lieutenant and
dispatched immediately to the regimental
command post by a runner next day the
translation of this map which was
returned to first battalion it showed
the japanese defensive plan
and proved very effective in eliminating
japanese from that area
when they attacked it not only marked
maps but also
documents of less apparent importance
may furnish the key to enemy plans
when combined with other information the
necessity for
prompt forwarding to hire headquarters
of all captured documents
must be impressed on all ranks and i'll
tell you why i wanted to bring that up
because this is something we get told
about intel all the time is
you know hey look you might find a piece
of paper that's got the word
purple on it and you bring that you know
hey this is what i found on target
that could be some code word that you
didn't know about it and it said wait
you don't know
so whenever you think you know
you're wrong whenever you think oh that
doesn't mean anything you're wrong
and so when someone is talking to you
and you think you know
you're wrong you don't know they've got
some perspective that you don't know
so listen to it listen to it
i have to put myself in check sometimes
when i'll get asked
a question like working with a client
and
someone will give me a question and i'm
telling you i have
you you i know you you have to
experience this too dave someone
someone raised their hand hey i want to
know
when it comes to cover and move if i'm
working with another department
and they don't we already know where
that question is going right there's
like a 98
chance that we know that they're going
to say hey this other department doesn't
care about me and they don't really
support us so what what am i supposed to
do then just keep support
we've heard that question we hear that
question a lot i always have to put
myself
in check because just because i think
that's what they're going to say
doesn't mean that's what they're going
to say it doesn't mean that there's not
some nuance to it it doesn't mean that i
can
spit out some module about how you you
know well you continue to support no no
listen to what they're saying don't
stop them from talking
you know the the minutes i see this in
group dynamics
you know there's a discussion going on
and someone's talking
and someone else someone else in the
group
will will cut them off
and this is another thing i talked about
on ef online
think about how disrespectful it is to
cut someone off right
like you might not say anything to me
but if you're talking and i just jump in
cut you off and just
just without regard just just start you
know cut you off
think about how do you consider that
disrespectful echo charles yes sir i do
most people recognize that that is
disrespectful
and so they try to stop themselves from
doing it they can't always control their
egos they can't always like let it
continue and i'll tell you i think being
on podcast have you ever noticed when
two people that have podcasts are
on the same podcast they'll let the
other person talk and it sort of let the
person complete thoughts because
podcast is sort of an amplified version
of if all of a sudden we're talking over
each other it's just painful to listen
to
but then if you get someone that's not
really a podcast type person or heaven
hasn't done a lot of fun they'll be
jumping in and wanting to talk and
and it makes it hard to listen to so
to me i think that's that's enhanced my
my my listening right because i if i
have a guest on here and they want to
talk it's like okay
i'm going to let them complete their
sentence and what i've realized over the
years is that when i let someone do that
there's usually some nuggets in there
that i didn't know about
so i'm actually going to listen to what
you have to say and the minute
when i hear someone at one at you know
we'll be working with a company and
you'll hear someone say
you know someone's mid-sentence and boom
gets cut off
and overrun and here's what i was
explaining on ef online the other day
we all recognize that as disrespectful
but it's seldom that we recognize the
opposite which is
when i'm listening to you i am showing
you respect
and you subconsciously know that like
the the person that you're talking to
when you listen to them
they subconsciously feel respected
which is a good which is a great thing
because we're trying to build a
relationship we're trying to build trust
and it's incredible how this tool of
listening is so powerful
in increasing the trust in relationships
that we can work to
better together as a team and yet it's
neglected all the time because
i think oh i already know what dave is
going to say
so i'm just going to bud in and start to
tell him what i think
well i am disrespecting dave
contrary if dave is talking and i listen
to him and i
nod my head and say yup i hear what
you're saying and i let him complete his
thoughts
not only am i not disrespecting him i
am respecting him and damn if you don't
see some just
mayhem go watch the news it's
insanity it's total insanity not just
the news
casters themselves or the guests that
they have come on for three minutes to
yell at each other but you know go watch
some
you know two people in this day and age
or five people or a hundred people
arguing with each other no one's
listening to anybody why jump into that
bar fight
right this is a verbal bar fight which i
obviously can escalate into
real fights and real problems nowadays
we're seeing all kinds of mayhem out in
the streets
and that mayhem is being caused by the
fact that no one's listening to each
other
and it starts with the disrespect of i'm
not gonna listen to you and by the way
when you when i cut you off and then you
try and cut me off back
what's my response i get louder
yeah and then you get louder and now
we're escalating next thing you know
we're throwing punches next thing you
know we're
hucking bottles and bricks and shooting
tear gas and we got a real freaking
problem
because we don't listen to each other
yeah the
a lot of times though when well when i
witness that or
see it or whatever i think anyway it
comes
not necessarily overtly disrespect but
it's almost like an absence of respect
because
more like they're just distracted or
maybe just focused
on their own like what they have to say
or their own significance or whatever
right so
you said yeah because if i think i know
what dave's going to say i'm going to
cut him off
and that's true and even if it's
subconscious it's true
you know because if i don't know what
you're going to say and i'm like kind of
curious i'm going to i'm going to wait
to hear it you know
but a lot of times people
they're either think they know what
they're going to say or they're too
eager about what they want to say
right so it kind of a lot of times it
comes back to like what kind of person
you are
you know so if you're like hey
everything that comes out of my my mouth
is just
gold you'll probably
interrupt people more like i tend to see
that kind of pattern you know
for sure and um
there's i will say the main time when i
jump in on somebody is like
i've got something flashing through my
brain and i don't want to lose it yeah
you don't want to forget it yeah there
is that to you
and yeah that actually seems like a
legitimate
like reason to interrupt sometimes yeah
but it's one of those things that i
think like you said a couple times where
it's like oh yeah it might
must not have been that important or
whatever you know if you forget it but
here's the thing though
there's a little dichotomy on that one
too what if dave's over here talking
like so much
he said so many things that read like
straight up required me to enter and be
like hey i got to stop you there you
know like that kind where it's like hey
that's right i gotta stop you there you
know kind of thing
but i didn't i just let him go meanwhile
he left me with
47 things that require my rebuttal or
whatever
and i didn't interrupt them it's kind of
like yeah that's a challenge
yeah but at the end of the day big
picture you might as well just be like
well at least i listened to dave and
everything he had to say yeah i mean
obviously we could break down start to
break down the social dynamics of
situations where
you know you'll have some disagreement
with you now i will tell you
i am much better off if dave is saying
something that i disagree with i
am much better off most of the time
letting him say what it is that i
disagree with rather than just jumping
in and being like
that that look it's it's disrespectful
i'm clearly not listening to you
right i'm cutting you off yeah so why am
i behaving that way
it's not good look if you
if dave wants to talk for seven minutes
and
rattle off you know like you said 47
points
maybe at some point i go you know maybe
at some point i say hey
can i just can we can we kind of address
these things one at a time
because you've you've just said three
different things and i'm gonna i'm gonna
get lost in what you're saying and
and i i want to talk about that first
thing i think you could do that
respectfully yeah like you got to put
effort into the respectful part of it
like i can respectfully interrupt yeah
really but if you're just throwing out
interruptions
yeah it's disrespectful there's
certainly different modalities of
interruption
that are that are you know
wildly different from and you know
what's cool what's interesting
is when you are face to face with
somebody you can tell
when the person wants to say something
right you can just look at their face
and they
they get a face and they have a
non-verbal communication telling you i
got something to say right now
and if you if i'm if dave's giving me
that look
res my my respect to him is to go
he's got something to say time to give
him a moment yeah
and the
i think well i'm speaking from
experience and i don't have much but
well actually no i do have a lot of
experience
listening to people talk but if you if
you
uh have a situation where okay the
person is talking and they're saying all
crazy stuff right that kind of requires
some correction or some interruption
right
or some discussion at a minimum yeah so
unless you guys are
actively working on solving a specific
problem we can which can happen like in
work or in a family or whatever but you
know how some people they just like to
talk and we're just having a friendly
conversation whatever
and they're just blabbing at the mouth
saying things that are just
some are true some are not true and
they're just going on and on like
they're all all correct right
and they won't be quiet you might as
well just not say anything
because at the end of the day it it does
you better
to just listen to everything they said
and you know what you know the old
saying
like yeah you don't want to talk you
want to listen because now you know
everything you already know and then you
know what they know
kind of thing you heard that one yeah
that's that's
uh from this podcast as a matter of fact
oh there you go boom so
so it's like that kind of situation you
know like you're not you're not
tasked necessarily to to effectively
change someone's mind every single time
so you might as well just keep your
mouth shut a lot of the time i mean
let's face it if you're going to have a
discussion with someone to
try and try and consolidate your ideas
together to become
to come up with a the strongest idea
then you have to converse with them and
whether they're a subordinate or a
superior or
a peer at some point you know in order
to progress
ideas you have to converse with them and
just sitting there and remaining silent
when people are saying things that you
totally disagree with
or to put in a better way you don't
fully understand their perspective
then we have to uncover that perspective
a little bit and you do that by asking
questions
and trying to figure out where they are
coming from
yeah you know i'm totally recalling a
very specific situation recently where i
was in the middle of this
straight up argument debate social
situation about political
quasi-political things and i just
witnessed just
mayhem going back and forth i didn't say
anything and i was like
oh yeah that's just jumping into a bar
fight that you're not yeah but i'm
thinking
like hey either one of you guys could
easily just be quiet and listen
and not say anything for the rest of the
whole time or whatever and
this whole like we'd all be better off
it's kind of like one of those
situations so i'm totally projecting
that right now
into this situation
what do you write down dave dude there's
a lot
there's a lot in what you just said
your thing that you're just talking
about when you're sitting there watching
these other two people
and when you're watching these other two
people have like what is kind of like a
ridiculous conversation where they're
arguing you're just sort of
the news or whatever and we're all just
sitting there as
observers and it looks completely
ridiculous to us as observers you see it
escalating you see it going nowhere
you see people digging in and when
you're just watching it
it's obvious how completely ridiculous
it is
the comment earlier is like that feeling
that when we
have something to say it's different and
this needs to be said
remember that when you're about to open
your mouth somebody else is going to
watch it and you're going to look
every bit as ridiculous to them as they
did to you
when you're talking about listening and
i have learned this
in my life i have learned to have a bias
to not talk
i learned that skill i wasn't born with
that skill i don't think anybody would
accuse
20 year old dave of having a bias for
listening that's a learned thing that i
have
done in my life the trick there is what
you have said a thousand times
is you actually have to listen because
of what you said before which is if i'm
talking and you're letting me talk
and i think you're listening to me i'll
talk i'll keep doing my thing but the
second i catch you
the eye roll like the heavy breathe or
whatever you're gonna do i'm like dude
this guy isn't listening to me
you actually have to listen and the only
way you will
truly listen to what the other person
says is if in your mind you believe that
you might get something out of it
because if you think you're like oh dude
here goes echo
he's gonna just go do what he does and
it's gonna be a complete waste of time
the minute i do that i'm gonna miss
something and
the actual listening part is a lot
harder than it sounds
because the conversation having your
head which is i know i'm right all these
points are wrong all these things are
saying are just complete waste
the active listening piece better come
from a place of authenticity or you
didn't get found out in a second
because your body language is going to
give the whole thing away and then you
might as well just cut them off right
there
because they're not listening because he
knows you're not listening to me
uh yeah there's a lot with that and as
simple as it sounds
to listen if it was so easy we wouldn't
have to say it over and over again
you're all fighting the urge like to
yeah yeah it's hard
yeah check
a little section here about
just just fraternization with the
prisoners
and and that they could not do that
which is
the reason the reason i said that is
because
here these guys are they're trying to
kill you for me this is just shows you
the the predominant spirit
spirit of the american servicemen
it says here it was necessary repeatedly
to warn the troops against incorrect
practice of fraternizing with prisoners
and giving them cigarettes which
interfered with the proper interrogation
troops had to be warned not to remove
pay books from the prisoners
because these books furnaced a check to
the interrogation officer of the
prisoner's statements
in regard to his organization previous
service so there's just these
you wouldn't think that after these guys
are trying to kill you that you'd want
to give them a cigarette
right and yet respect
speed marching
commanding general third division sicily
the importance of physical condition
cannot be overemphasized speed marching
proved of great value and developing
physical condition
eliminating the unfit and instilling
confidence and pride in the individual
as a general training objective all
units prepared for a landing on defended
beaches and in advance inland of about
five miles speed marching continued
each unit being required to complete
five miles in one hour eight miles in
two hours and 20 miles in five hours
once a week this training was largely
responsible for the speed with which the
assault of this division was executed
there you go um physical conditioning
it he points out this and this is so
obvious
instilling confidence and pride mean
what a
factor what a factor way the warrior kid
books you know
get a kid that doesn't can't do a
pull-up right
and all of a sudden you can do a pull-up
you can lift your own weight
you can stand up a little straighter and
get your team working out
that's what i'm saying
writing messages reports and messages
major robert wilson field artillery
italy the who
what when where and why were often not
contained in reports both oral and
written battalion regimental s2s and the
men themselves indicated that during
maneuvers and in training problems
they had thought that this subject had
been mastered but that in combat it was
ignored or forgotten
as to clarity the axiom of a message can
be understood it will be mis if a
message
can be misunderstood it will be
misunderstood was well proven
the comment here writing messages during
a
unit training program is one thing
writing clear
specifically worded messages and orders
under combat conditions is quite another
theoretical training in message writing
must be
supplemented by constant practice and
supervision
in the field that
is why i was an english major so i could
learn how to write
a section here on dirt breeding
infection
half the evacuations from the battalion
was due to infection caused by minor
scratches and to that i would say get
yourself some
warrior kid soap so you can stay
oh come on this is another one of those
life ones a foxhole in time
saves lives lieutenant colonel bogart
infantry
fifth army italy although the average
american soldier will dig a foxhole or
slit trench when the artillery or mortar
shells are falling in his vicinity
only a few of those i saw would dig them
prior to that time
when they did dig them they were usually
quite shallow
it was always very easy to tell a german
foxhole from the american the former
were always much deeper
many casualties occurred from shellfire
which i believe would have been avoided
had proper foxholes or slit trench been
dug
in and this is you know the code the
evaluation the protocol
are you prepared for life emergencies
are you prepared for emergency
situations
we as americans i totally agree with
this
we don't like to worry about anything
until it slaps us in the face in fact in
the seal teams i used to tell my
leadership
no one worries about anything until they
get slapped in the face with it like no
one's really concerned about that
until you get hit with it and all of a
sudden you gotta execute that mission
and you don't have the gear that you
need
so let's get the gear we need let's get
do the rehearsals we're supposed to do
be proactive
i can kind of go for little things too
oh 100
goes to little things well yeah so these
lit and these little things
kind of so the other night i'm at home
it's bedtime go sleep right in the
middle of the night here
you know what that is right no idea
that's your uh
perimeter security your detector a fire
detector with a nine volt battery that's
dead
that's dying exactly right and bro
you think you can if you don't have nine
volt batteries at what three a.m
and know where they are and know where
they are yeah
but let's say you don't have them
straight up i mean let's face it do you
just have random nine volt batteries in
your in your house
yes i know exactly where they are i have
two for each fire detector in my house
here's the thing i'm a father now
so so do i oh yeah so do i but i'll tell
you this before i had kids before i had
a
thing life whatever that smoke detectors
i didn't have nine volt batteries just
hanging around
straight up didn't have didn't even
think about it years oh yeah 100
i i guess my wife when she was growing
up they they didn't have batteries
like you know the her mom and dad just
batteries weren't on the list
yeah and so my wife is a battery hoarder
and stockpiler
you want a nine volt you want a triple a
you want a double a
what do you want open up that cabinet
and they're in there they're ready bro
i'm with you my wife's the exact same
she gets a little bit excited when the
batteries run out on something oh
it's like hey the battery's out on this
thing oh hold on
and she goes and digs out of ce2325 for
my watch
actually i think my watch is at 3232.
yeah this was gonna say that's the c3
that one's i think that's a scale you
put that in one of those little scales
it might be the well i don't know either
way yeah i don't know either but
i do know that i did have a nine volt
battery that night
but i was thinking to myself bro what if
i didn't have a nine volt battery
brad no we're not sleeping tonight you
only you're not sleeping then
that and it doesn't have to do just that
night now you got the whole next day you
got to contend with
you see insane really very this is
because you're paranoid
no a fire or that beep is bothering you
the beep is going to keep you up
i'm with you man that's that's because
because i'll tell you what happens it
turns out that that fire detector
that beeps every 60 seconds can't be
destroyed
yeah you could take a sledgehammer to it
and just break it without it will
still beep so what you're talking about
that's the slap in the face which is
you're totally unprepared for the
situation now you're up all night
you think you solve the problem the
second you get into bed lights all
covers babe i gotta sort beep
and then you're up again so i'm with you
it's true
i learned this lesson 30-ish years ago
so i've got those nine volts at the
ready yes sir
yeah in in one time you know how i found
that out that you can't
you can't stop that thing i was like
okay i was like yes no problem
like i'll just take out the battery how
can it beat with no power
simply can't be can't happen it's not
like you know where does it get the
power to beep from
where does that come from apparently
they thought ahead you know in the case
of a real emergency it's one of those
things and a little bit more important
than your sleep that night if you're
unprepared you know so it made sense
when i kind of thought through it but
nonetheless i was still
faced with this problem like this
beeping lucky it wasn't in the middle of
the night but whatever so i was like
yeah i got to do it
i would've had a real problem that day
but i had to put it in the drawer
you could still hear it but it was just
way more quiet so when i got a battery
or whatever
later on i found out yeah it can't be
disabled that's the whole reason it
beeps
destroyed cannot can't it can't be
bargained with either
but yeah man nonetheless that's the
point it can go for small things too
you see what i'm saying just be prepared
how about this how about just keep some
nine
nine volt batteries all good problems
beeps three am
three pm whenever you all kill batteries
batteries low
you know are we good over there
equitables with that all right let's
move on
section three mountain operations they
go through a big battalion attack here
go into a lot of detail it's another
another from another
uh perspective on the battle on the
attu island and there's
there's some detail there's some maps
and charts and you should go check it
out online so you can kind of get the
full benefit of that but i just wanted
to hit a couple highlights and going
back to communications here a rather
elaborate system of communications was
established
to enable the battalion commander to
control the fire
of supporting weapons in furtherance of
tactical plans
the artillery radio radio as well as
telephone was set up
at the battalion commander's op on top
of the
hog back which is one of these little
terrain features a sound power telephone
was run from the mortar op
back to the battalion commander likewise
one from the 75s the telephone was also
run
from the op to the officer in charge of
all 37 millimeter
firing radio and telephone control was
run to all companies in the battalion
so the reason i highlight that that's a
lot of communications
and if we're counting on all those
communications we may
not get what we we might not get what we
want
goes into this here they get into
contact we saw the first one at 0 4 30
in the morning he was a century and we
were then 50 yards
of him he stood up against the skyline
and was shaking out a grass mat
lieutenant brown
motioned to us to get up a little under
the ledge to our front and then he shot
the jap the shot must have awakened
others as we worked up
over the ledge a jap machine gunner
began firing at us we stayed down until
the first
excited burst had gone over then we
raised up and returned fire several japs
had holes near the edge of the ledge
we were under and they began to throw
grenades over but the hill below is so
steep that most of the grenades rolled
down and exploded
out of range below us the machine gun
was firing again but several of our men
were close enough to
to the ledge to lob grenades over the
machine gun itself was out of
grenade range but some of the japs near
the edge
caught hell from the grenades
are you feeling lucky when the people
that are throwing grenades at you they
like bounce over your position and don't
hurt you i think that might have been my
whole point there
the radio fails so this is why i get
concerned about
about communications and as a former
radio man
it definitely freaks me out lieutenant
brown tried again and again to contact
battalion headquarters or the artillery
and i'm fast forwarding a little bit or
the artillery with the radio but the set
refused to function the radio man worked
with it and tried again but failed the
platoon was reorganized and we started
up again
they're assaulting this hill we got as
high as the ledge once more
and had started over the top on the
table
above when the jap opened up with
machine guns again we needed artillery
and needed it bad every time we stuck
our noses up
a hailstorm of bullets cracked across
them the radio man was trying
frantically to contact
anybody in the valley below us but the
set remained silent
several men had crawled around to the
left and threw grenades at the japs
near the edge of the table but the
machine guns remained
out of range our men were driven back to
the cover of the ledge with several
wounds
artillery if we only had artillery we
could observe the fire we knew where the
guns were
if we could only get some fire we'd walk
over the damn mountains
the radio man was desperate he tried to
set again but it was silent
in a rage he threw it down the hill
yeah so there's a bunch of things to
think about there just you know your
communications cannot be relied upon
you have to have some kind of backup
plan
and if you're if you're expecting you
can be able to make
communications when when they're really
going to be made needed
that is the time they're going to fail
that is murphy's law if you say okay
dave here's what's going to happen we
have this whole
complicated plan and then when you get
to this point
radio me and that's when we'll execute
that radio call has a four percent
chance of making communications
if everything hinges upon one call the
weight of that
hinge just just has
carm karmatic is that a word a karmic
karmic impact on that communication
system
and it's not going to work great so
their attack gets repulsed um
he says he said we heard the guns in the
valley begin firing the attack was on we
had failed and we felt bad about it
about it they had the drop on us they're
going through the main attack
the japs were holding the pass on the
high ground on both sides of the front
two the ones on the right could fire
into the backs of the attackers
of the left and vice versa it was rough
going
lieutenant clevzy got me
up and we went around the second section
to get them started up the hill the
attack was going okay but it was an
awfully tough one bullets were flying
all over the hillside just uphill from
the second section
was a jap 37 millimeter we had watched
them fire from that position several
days before and we knew there were japs
in that trench
the main attack was moving around to the
left as we started up the hill finally
the
fire got so heavy that the machine gun
squad took cover
in a little draw until we could grenade
the trench above us to clean it out
then they were to come on up sergeant
tom kovic
private first class william marshall and
i started up with lieutenant clevzy
we had crawled on our bellies to within
25 yards of the trench
when a sniper raised up and shot
marshall in the air we shot at the
sniper we threw grenades into the trench
we crawled up rapidly then ready to move
in behind our grenades and another
sniper popped his head up out of the
hole just above us
lieutenant clevzy fired his carbine just
as the jap fired lieutenant
toppled over a little bank and lay still
he was dead
i was just bringing up the rifle as the
jet my rifle as the jap
duct then from across the valley the
japs spotted us
and they gave us hell machine guns
rifles and 37 millimeter began pounding
the area
finally the intense shelling slowed down
and we dashed for the open end of the
jap trench we had grenaded
the trench led around to the point of
the hill we crawled down the trench and
found where the jabs were located
when we stuck our heads right up in the
face of a burst of machine gun fire
some men from company f had come over to
help us but were stymied
we couldn't raise up long enough to fire
we couldn't get close enough to throw
grenades
finally we decided to see if we could
get some mortar fire on the position in
some way
corporal alfred heyman started back up
to check
on the mortar possibilities and while we
waited and rested the jab position was
slightly below us
and about a hundred yards further into
the pass they were firing almost
constantly at the troops we could see
moving out in the valley
and on the opposite side of the pass we
were quite high up
on the side of cold mountain after
nearly two hours of lying in the trench
and waiting
we heard one of the men behind holler
here heeman
up here he and a man from company h the
infantry
were caught crawling up along the little
ravine laying wire they had found a
company h mortar
and had a line right to it the big fight
up on the mountain had almost gotten to
the top
but the forces across the pass were
getting hell from the guns below us
we got the phone all set up and
carefully poked a little dirt
a little hole in the dirt side of the
trench a week so that one
man could see the whole jap position
below then we called mortar
and the fun started we were only about
100 yards from where the shells were
striking and the ground shook
they fired several rounds close and then
they began to drop right into position
finally we called and told them we were
moving in and not to fire the position
was like a big wheel
was a big wheel like a fair with holes
all around it and the spokes were
connecting the trenches
with a big center installation in the
hub two japanese machine
guns in the 37 millimeter that had fired
at us during the previous week were
captured and destroyed there
we tossed six dead japs out the hole and
brought them
brought up our guns up and set them in
the jab holes
we there we sat that night just daring
the little so-and-so's to come up man
what positions they had
one little
fight within a battle you know one
little tiny fight within a battle and
think of all those decisions that got
made and all those
actions that took place and the mistakes
that had to be covered for
and the initiative that had to be shown
and the bravery and the courage i mean
it's just
it's leadership and that's that's what
it is it's leadership
um they they go through a bunch of this
information um continuing on
they there's another group that takes
another point and again
look these guys i can pretty much
guarantee are no longer alive but
this is these are quotes these are what
these guys are saying
happened um you know things like
lieutenant walzack saying
check your bayonets as they get ready to
do this assault
and there's just so there's some some
other little battles within fights
within battles that they cover and then
it gets into this comment section
these accounts bring out some of the
characteristics of mountain warfare
in which success depends more upon
proper adaptation of available means to
the terrain
than upon their power so
the wet the way you adapt is more
important
it continues maneuver of small units
and the initiative and leadership of
subordinate commanders
are of the highest importance in
mountain warfare
the actions of small semi-independent
units in
seizing or defending heights in or in
fighting to seize or block passes
become of increasing importance
so once again even though this book
starts off
with the extreme dichotomy of discipline
of following orders
it comes back always to decentralize
command
an individual initiative by subordinate
leaders to make
things happen
he's talking about mountain warfare
there and and getting to this idea of
i mean that's it that's leadership right
it's leadership is going to be the
deciding factor here
because the terrain is so
it's so impossible to predict there's so
many different things and places and
outcroppings and
all these different and even tell the
story what great position
they had in that previous example with
the japanese
life is more like mountain warfare than
it is there's gonna be these big open
fields of your life gonna
just reveal themselves and you're just
gonna plan your your your move down down
the road
there are so many things that are
popping up when we're talking to
companies right now
they're describing that same terrain in
their
business lives of all these unpredicted
and unexpected things
and it isn't the strength of their brand
and it isn't you know the qua
it's the leadership that's navigating
these companies through and we're
talking about the terrain of mountain
warfare
that's what life is it's not just this
easy straight road from a to b
and you just march down and everything
is is clean and how crazy that has to be
that at
every single turn something comes up and
the tool
the only tool that you have to get past
that is leadership
and you know what i like also about this
analogy and the way it ties into the
entire
concept of
yes of leadership but really even more
specifically to
ownership and extreme ownership and and
that is this this is what's so beautiful
about this
you can't move those mountains
you cannot do you cannot those mountains
are what they are and that's what that's
what
what triggered that thought in my mind
was you said um there's all these
variables but what's interesting is
you're looking at them
you know for days you understand you can
see it on the map you can look at it
there's this mountain
and you know what you can't move
that mountain and what you have to do is
you have to move yourself and
this is you know i talk about this in
jiu jitsu when someone's across the side
on you
i can bench press you an inch you know
maybe two inches i don't care if you
have a 500 pound bench press when you've
got a person that's
mobile and they're they're securing you
and they've got your
chest compressed like it you can't bench
press them off of you
you can move them just enough then you
have to move
it's incumbent upon you and so we can't
move mountains
what we have to do is adapt what we have
to do is figure out how to utilize those
things
and what the important thing is even
though we can't
move those mountains the person that
figures out how to utilize that
terrain is the one that's gonna win
you utilize the terrain it's something
that i have no control over
but i control how i interact with that
mountain and i know where i need to be
and i know i understand the angles and i
understand what
ravine will give me cover and i
understand where it exposes me
even when he's talking about hey this
the way the japanese were set up
i was like oh they can hit these guys
here
in the flank and they can shoot these
guys in the back that's the position
that they have
that's a freaking horrible situation to
be rolling into
horrible situation to be rolling into
so when you look at things instead of
sitting there and going saying
i wish the market was different i wish
the competitor would do something
different
i wish my employees would act in a
different way
these are all things that you can look
at you can wish all day long just like
you can wish that mountain moves but
that mountain's not going anywhere
so you need to maneuver you need to take
ownership of that situation and make
things happen
there's a whole bunch of sections here
engineer operations tanks
infantry notes and jungle operations
one one section here japanese centers of
resistance were bypassed and isolated
again how often do we
say oh dave doesn't like this part of my
plan so i'm gonna
attack him on that instead of saying
okay dave's gonna dig in right there
cool i'll maneuver around it
right bypass i'm gonna start thinking
about that a little bit more often in my
daily life
how can i bypass maybe not when it comes
to working out because echo charles
pointed out that might not be the best
plan but
if it's things that i don't want to
engage in why am i engaging in them if i
don't have to
if i can isolate and bypass and not make
it part of my gig that's fine
frontal attacks were uniformly
successful
when assisted by a flank attack
on many occasions the flank attack
preceded the frontal attack
coming into japanese positions from the
rear and completely disrupting their
defense plans
in almost all cases the maneuver used by
units of all sizes from division to
squad
was the envelopment of one or both
flanks yeah
resistance was made by resistance was
bypassed encircled and reduced later
so the frontal assault works when it's
not actually a funnel
that's awesome when you're doing
something else as well
yes that's so legit uh section on
section on automatic weapons night
operation security measures
security at night lines of communication
patrol reports in general the distance
covered by the patrols was much
less than expected of them the
difficulties of terrain
caused by many patrol leaders to feel
that they had covered two or three times
as much ground than they had actually
covered
this must be taken to account when
evaluating patrol reports
these are people that think that they
know like hey i was
there isn't that crazy you could be
looking at me totally convinced that you
went two kilometers
and it turns out when we retrace your
steps you went
whatever 700 yards 700 meters
one last section to cover here um
yeah this last section is very
interesting evacuation methods
informal report solomon islands
evacuation of casualties was by hand
carry
litter bearers cable litter slings
across
jungle gullies improvised sleds
or drags down steep inclines improvised
litter racks on quarter ton jeeps small
boats on mountain streams or along the
coast
and finally by field ambulances to
clearing stations or hospitals
how's that for a nightmare when you when
you were in fallon did you were you ever
a down pilot
yeah yeah did you get carried out on
litters yeah you got a helicopter you
stage there and then they come out and
get you like
the metal it's like a metal basket
basically yeah the litter
did you ever get carried by a seal
platoon like eight kilometers
no okay i know exactly what you're
talking about i was never the i was
never the down air crew that got
actually physically pulled right it's
not fun when you're getting carried
because you're getting dropped you're
getting slammed you're getting
all over the place and usually we would
stick guys with ivs you know or like we
would
try and do some medical training on them
as well but
good lord i want you to think about
everything that i just said hand carry
cable litters across jungle gullies
improvised sleds
drags down steep so you're wounded and
what's the method of doing okay we're
gonna drag you down a steep incline
improvised litter on a on a quarter ton
jeep imagine that thing bouncing around
small boats think about a nightmare
and this is where you start to realize
what a nightmare i'm talking about
evacuation by litter bearers was
difficult
tiring time consuming and involved
distances
averaging two or three miles and five to
six miles
in some instances many more litter
bearers had to be utilized than
under ordinary conditions litter carry
in many cases required as high as
16 carriers per patient
over almost impassable terrain and can
be counted
as least efficient
so it takes 16 people
to evacuate somebody two miles or three
miles
where evacuation by litter was necessary
bearers worked in relays
eight or even 16 men accompanying each
litter relieving one another
in literacy and in cutting narrow paths
through the dense jungle
16 people to move a wounded man
i mean that's just crazy
and obviously it wasn't all of them but
they're saying hey sometimes it was
eight and
i'll tell you the reason i was asking
you if you've ever been in that position
number one you get beat up but
you know when we would do desert
training
when i was running desert training man
those guys would do some down man
carries and i'm sure
some of the guys that are hearing me
saying that now are
smiling with pleasant memories of going
eight kilometers through the imperial
valley desert
carrying and eventually like the first
you know if we had a
uh a troop that hadn't been through
before
or didn't have any experience say oh
yeah hey which i you know what's your
casualty evacuation plan oh we're just
gonna put two guys on them and we're
gonna do i forget today there's some
name there's a couple carries
you know there's a standard fireman's
carry oh we're just going to fireman's
carrying okay
cool see how that see how that works out
for you
you can't i mean it's it's you can do it
for 100 meters 200 meters
300 meters
400 meters you're on
night vision you're in the worst
freaking terrain rocks
shale rocks all over the place
and it was great because as we would do
these drills
and as guys realized what a traumatic
impact it was when you took casualties
and how you had to adjust what you
thought you'd be able to do
because you can't just freaking rambo
you can ramble somebody up
i mean i've done it like okay grab a guy
and i'm going to carry him 150 meters
200 meters
by the time you get to that 200 meter
mark like you're when you get
to the spot you're just falling down
with the guy
300 meters you're just falling down and
you're exhausted
and you've lost your weapon and your
night vision and his gear is gone
it's a disaster until you figure out
okay when this happens here's well
here's some procedures that we need to
do
talks about the improvised jeep
ambulances talks about
evacuation by water
physical fitness the arduous
and fatiguing litter caring demonstrated
the need for physical fitness
on the part of medical department
personnel which should
correct the impression that physically
impaired
individuals can be utilized throughout
medical
department activities
so this idea that you can have a bunch
of you know guy that's injured or hurt
and have him working in medical
being a stretcher bearer is completely
and utterly wrong and that's
well that's a a wrap on the highlights
that i had from this
and you know i i don't know when i think
about this whole thing and we've been
referring back to it the whole time the
so many good lessons but the the the the
key take away from me
is that whole idea of leader versus
inertia
and you know as soon as i said that
today dave i looked at you and i saw you
had about a thousand thoughts going
through your mind on what that means and
how many ways that we can apply that
it's like the world is conspiring
against us
and it's human nature to neglect
our duties and i know that sounds crazy
and sure there's some outliers out there
that are proactive going to make things
happen
but you've got to assess as a leader
that human nature
is to be lazy and to be careless and you
need to
definitely look in the mirror
because it's not always just going to be
the people that you lead it's going to
be
you
and that section where they talk about
the hardest job that you have as a
leader is getting things done
getting things done by people who know
that they're supposed to do them and
even in some cases know that
those things can cost in their lives
failure to do things
failure to take action
so don't allow that be on the lookout
how nice is it sometimes when you make
the connection
between something that's there that
you've always known was there but you
never
pid'd it and by that echo i mean
positively identified
like hey i know now everyone that's
listened to this today now
knows that that's a problem
and and look we all kind of knew it
right i mean i talked about it
disbelief's freedom field manual hey you
know we're
gonna want to move like that's that's a
real thing i get it
we all kind of get it but how about a
pid on it
and now when it starts happening either
with you or with your team
or with your family or with your friends
you can p id it and then you can address
it properly
and you can start with yourself
you can start by making things happen
speaking of making things uh happen echo
charles yes
how can we do what we're supposed to do
what we know we should do
on top of pid we pid it oh yeah
yeah same thing with complaining right
remember we pid that long time ago
complaining uh blaming another one yeah
those are two those are two good things
once you recognize once you pid those
things man that blame one
oh yeah because if you don't pid the
blame it'll like sneak in
away with it too really it's great oh
yeah you can be like
yeah hey yeah i really shouldn't have
done that you know it could have helped
you know if you would have gave me the
heads up or whatever but you're right i
shouldn't shouldn't have done that did
you see the blame
that stupid mountain was totally
blocking our position
yeah kind of make it makes it kind of
harder but no you're right i should have
done it you see i'm saying see me taking
ownership but
slipping in the blame you pid the blame
you can see it that's what i'm saying
anyway so don't do that when you're um
working out which okay so i worked out
today
actually no no i thought about working
out today
but then i got into this deep
conversation with my wife okay about
some important stuff
the window closed the window totally
closed oh it closed
it straight up closed yeah cause the
conversation went long i had to come
here you see what i'm saying
yeah i had a window closing last night
it was
i had something my wife was making
dinner i was like i can fit in a run
right now before dinner
oh a late workout no just a run i
already worked out
the run's not a workout so
late night so i my wife was cooking
dinner i had like a 40 minute window my
wife says oh
by the way someone's coming over to grab
something i'm like
okay the run's not happening now the
windows just
i'm kind of i'm kind of shrugging it off
like oh well you know window closed you
know
no run but then i pid it and i said you
know what
i ate dinner which i hate i ate dinner
and then i ran
just to punish myself i pulled one of
those before brad that's that's
so true right there so that right there
what you just did what you went what you
what you experienced
same deal right you got the 40 minute
window or for running
right because you got it all planned on
your head it goes beyond the run it goes
like
the stuff you did before is in your mind
stuff you're gonna do after the run
dinner all this other stuff
and the stuff after that in your mind
does not include the run because the run
is already done
that's it this whole formula right there
in your mind yeah so now that little
window closed boom where's that run
gonna fit in
i already know in my mind what i'm gonna
do after dinner which is after the run
which already happened
right what i'm doing put the run there
no it's already occupied in your brain
you see what i'm saying
but the thing is it doesn't work like
that you put it there as as
essentially like an excuse yeah yeah you
know what's crazy
i so as i was running so now i'm running
20 minutes after i get done eating
i don't think i've run on a full stomach
for
15 years think about that 15 years i
don't think i and i don't think i'll run
on a full stomach again for another 15
years because it felt
freaking awful and i don't roll i don't
work out on
on a full stomach i don't like doing any
of that i can get away with like a
workout depending on the workout i'm not
squatting on a full stomach because
that's just not good
but maybe i can do some pull-ups on a
full but yeah i was
running on a full stomach i won't do
that again i i would next time
because i wanted to you know like eat
with my family you know that like let's
eat time i would have eaten one fork
full
of food and then not eaten and put it in
the and then go for it
hang with the family go for a run come
back yeah that would be the power move
and that's actually one of many power
moves really the other power move is how
about this yeah good for you you know
running on a
full stomach in 15 years freaking run on
a full stomach oh i did
that's what i'm saying though you know
what i'm saying like there's all kinds
of things that
you can just push through and still get
it in that's what i'm saying
even all the way down to hey who cares
if you're there if this person is coming
over
yeah true that's the end of the world
huh if you're not there
you know not the end of the world but
maybe not
the best move at that time okay then we
shift to the full stomach situation we
did it you know or maybe the half
stomach
oh you know i'm just saying that the
opportunity is always there you know
this was
in line with sort of this evolving
attitude that i have
now of of of kind of a going hard
against the weakness
yeah i was like not only am i going to
run still
i'm going to run on a full stomach and
just want to puke yeah
a whole freaking time because that's how
you know so but i did the same exact
thing but it was it was less complex for
sure but it was like the window was
closing
like i can't get my full workout now
because dinner time
like yeah you know i'm gonna eat dinner
you ever just do something super short
in psycho though if you let the window
close but you don't want to let it shut
so you're like okay cool oh you want to
be like that cool
yeah just going to go in here and do
like mayhem for
18 minutes yeah yeah because you can get
a freaking good workout in 18 minutes
yeah it's probably not going to be the
plan to work out in my situation
but yeah yeah i'll do that a few i'd
done that a few times when i had to like
come here somewhere where
if i'm late it kind of affects other
people and you know it's like it's my
fault anyway you know
so i'll oh yeah i'll do that kind of
stuff for sure but i did it with the
dinner thing and i did a metcon on a
full stomach
and i even told you about it the next
day i was like i was doing anyway it's a
long story but yeah
well speaking of timelines
let's rock and roll yes sir all right
okay look we're doing workouts we're not
doing excuses we're what fighting
against weakness punishing
weak weakness thoughts we're punishing
ourselves for those
thoughts or considerations but when you
do that you know you join
your bodies take a beating specifically
your joints from time to time
okay choco is supplementation
for that so supplements are chocolate
fuel
joint warfare for your joints super
krill oil
for your joints vitamin d
is it super vitamin d we'll just say
it's pretty good how about that because
i'd say yeah super super it's not called
super vitamin d
maybe we need your help with branding on
that one no man like you helped us with
super krill i didn't know kind of funny
either way it's vitamin d nonetheless
i'm gonna change the name too
super vitamin d all day yeah for 100
percent so you know get on that one
um also cold war
wasn't it called like some cold killer
or something yeah before you can't say
that kind of stuff don't say that
because it kills colds you can't say
that you can't say that that's a
bad advertising what's the word
so we can't say that but we can't go to
war against colds yes
missile uh defense tank
what is it the tank the cold war missile
defense i say that cold war missile
defense
yes sir you say that i do all day i
fight the war against colds every day
let's see also discipline
regular discipline and the
supplementation discipline
cans powder pills whatever you need yeah
whatever your mentality that little
yeah big little psychological hitter a
little bit of
a little bit of go jocko palmer
taking the lead sorry is it taking the
lead it's leading right now
it's leading i agree yeah i agree first
flavor school yeah
i had the long drive to montana
sure 17 hours
all one go one go one go nope i mean i
stopped for gas
fuel of course yes sir but the cool
thing was
uh just kind of fyi for your research in
the future
two discipline go let's cans
much one and about one at about
midnight maybe one o'clock in the
morning and i had another one
at like two or
three that's that's the kind of that's
the that's
once the sun's coming up you're good
yeah when's the sun coming about rock
and roll
but there's i guess it's maybe around
four o'clock in the morning like you
don't see as soon as you start seeing
sun your body goes oh cool
we're awake now yeah it's day it's that
3 34
4 30 where your body thinks you should
be asleep right freaking now
yeah get that hitter boy
17-hour drive so when when you time it
like when do you leave like night time
essentially yep yeah you're right post
time
dinner departure yeah okay
i dig it i don't think i've ever driven
17 hours ever ever
cool i'm not sure how valuable that
information is but those are the facts
uh yeah so mulk don't forget about mulk
don't forget about you you probably need
extra protein i had a mulk
before i came here today just because i
have doms
sure and i was like meaning delayed
onset muscle soreness
sure a little heavy on squats yesterday
and i have a lot of doms so i just
kicked down some mulch
a little extra protein plus i was in the
mood for dessert even though i didn't
have any lunch
so anyways all this stuff choco white
tea kids
kids wore your kid milk you get all the
stuff at the vitamin shop
we also make ed or also you can get it
at origenmaine.com
if you want to support this podcast if
you want to support america in general
which if you want to support america in
general good on you
get yourself some quality items yeah get
yourself a ghee
for your jujitsu get yourself a rash
guard for your jiu jitsu
t-shirts jeans jeans
american denim boots you guys have the
um
delta 68 then the what's the regular one
called again
the factory jeans factory genes is there
like another what do you call it a model
no that's the two models right now
factory genes heavier
delta genes lighter which i know this is
a little strange
but you know not man i dig it um you
know
delta 68. montana was wearing a
lightweight hoodie
not you though no it wasn't me but they
told me
like to tell you that they supported
approved
in montana by the way which is
surprising you can't argue with the
people
i mean it's just you know it goes
against your whole thing
you know anyway yes origin main.com
that's where all this stuff exists
it's something american-made fully also
jocko has a store it's called
jacostore.com this is where you can get
discipline equals freedom deathcore good
worth all deathcore technically
technically for sure so yeah just
blending hoodies
shirts hats
lightweight hoodies that's or rash
guards for sure
we've got some new stuff new stuff oh
you've been plotting all kinds of stuff
over there we have a few new things uh
really good stuff utility
and more utility we
we have a shirt coming that may become
sort of like the shirt i'm not making
any predictions
just for me personally it might become
the shirt that i
end up wearing a lot you literally won't
wear anything else it'll be like
remember back in the day when you still
always wear victory even before the
podcast
i look at all the old pictures of
ourselves victory shirt
as long as you've known me yeah it's
like you can't even recognize you if you
don't have that victory shirt on
if even a picture like that even exists
which i don't think it does
it's going to be one of those well we've
had victory for
what 10 years yeah and so
for a long time and we've been doing the
podcast for
five uh something like that coming up on
five
so that means for five complete years
before this podcast
the the one free t-shirt i had which i
had a lot of them
sure actually john dudley asked me that
the we were up in montana like the
the fifth day in a row i posted up in a
victory t-shirt
he said do you just wear that or wash it
or you have a thousand of them i go
no i don't have a thousand of them but i
got ten oh yeah
we have the light one and the dark one
either way that's why you have the light
one and the dark one of this
new shirt i'll let you make it you know
i'll let you uh what do you call it uh
roll it out as it were reveal it anyway
review
it's jocko's jam big time anyway
jocklestore.com that's where you can get
your uh
that's where you can go get your stuff
to represent while you're on the path
put it that way some new stuff so uh
keep that in mind
look if you wanna know about new stuff
or
how should i wanna know about new stuff
dave what shirt is that
this is a deathcore shirt but it's
available
it's absolutely available it's called
ops you have black ops
you're wearing it and he has i know i
have the black one declassified
the declassified version but here's the
deal the difference between a white
shirt
and a black shirt in the california sun
is extreme
yes sir so i like to wear a white shirt
i don't have this one
echo charles yeah easy yeah things
that must suck really but hey man
you know i know a guy and maybe we'll
get you one cool yeah yeah
so yes if you want a uh deathcore black
ops or
declassified chocolatestore.com
declassified
yes i like it i i like it when you
sort of mingle with military terms
normally if you're suspect you you
contact me yeah
you say hey what would this be a correct
usage of the word whatever yeah or
appropriate yeah yeah often times i say
you know not really yeah there was one
thing i did and i think
yeah it was you oh the high speed low
drag i was gonna use that in some
it wasn't a shirt but it was in some
other stuff i was doing
and you're like hey don't do that don't
do that one because it wasn't like
appropriate
yeah i forget what it was because high
speed low drag is definitely a
term yes and it has a meaning i forget
the way you used it i used it in a more
serious way than it should be oh yeah
that's not a serious term yeah it's kind
of like
that guy is high speed low draft yeah
like for real it's kind of like
you might say it about a pair of gucci
looking shooting glasses
yeah yeah yeah that's what i learned uh
yeah so anyway back to what i was saying
hey if you want to get be
in the know we have an email list on
jocko's store if you want to be in the
know about some stuff i
i don't abuse this list at all in fact i
i under utilize it actually
i tried try my best to save it for
important stuff
the stuff that i think it's important so
if you want to know about a new product
some new board shorts that may or may
not be on the way
or something like this if you're on the
email list you will get notified before
everybody
i'm not saying our stuff sells out what
if you have important information
what if you have important information
about rolling frying pans
uh well you know hey look does that make
the list usually stuff like that no
thank you
bill for inquiring i mean we do have to
clarify i guess and
so that's correct but important in
information about jacqueline store sign
up for that email list
hey we'll get that info to you and
you'll have it before everybody else
and boom won't be all good will you put
the new t-shirt on there
yes i well yeah you said that was mine
to announce yeah that might be yours to
announce
or you just send the email how about
that okay i'll send an email out when
the new shirt is
released uh subscribe to the podcast if
you haven't already
we also have some other podcasts we have
uh the new podcast which is
isn't on its own channel yet it's called
the unraveling
it was called the thread we had to
change the name we also have the
grounded podcast we also have the
warrior kid podcast
we have a youtube channel by the way
we have a youtube channel
that has all these podcasts
on them you can see us except for the
first seven because the first seven
there was no video involved it's just
voice oh yeah even though we did the
first podcast on like some kind of live
stream
if you tried to yeah i
remember we were having some trouble
technically yeah
so anyways or and then also
some of these are there's some excerpts
in there as well yeah
sure and there's also some things that
echo charles
experiments with random and very
over the top special effects
on on just normal videos
and he'll put 98 special effects into a
two-minute video but this video right
here which is gonna be
three hours and 40 minutes long there
will be no
no excitement other than just watching
me crack up at my own jokes
at the end of this podcast no additional
excitement needed in my opinion
so far there could be so many good
little ex like
extra additions and easter eggs or
whatever you call them
in this particular podcast talking about
flanking people
mortars 37 millimeters 88
grenades just think of all the cool
stuff that could be flying around in
here
it's blowing up anyway also
jocko has or we have an
album with tracks called psychological
warfare
you know if you don't know what this is
don't worry this this is going to help
you it helps us
so we're talking about inertia right
uh object that is in st rest
stays at rest tends to stay at rest and
it's if it's in motion so anyway
if you're battling to get into motion
when you're currently at rest and it's
hard sometimes it's hard
i got you this will help that is what
i'm saying psychological warfare okay
jocko telling you what to do not
necessarily what to do but
why you should do what you should do
it's about accurate right yeah yeah
that's available wherever you need mp3s
also if you want a visual representation
of those types of messages go to
flipsidecanvas.com
my brother dakota myers
makes stuff to hang on your wall got a
bunch of books the code
the evaluation the protocol leadership
strategy and tactics field manual way
the warrior kid one two and three mikey
and the dragons
discipline equals freedom field manual
extreme ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership you can get those books
pretty much anywhere
books are sold we have a consulting
agency for leadership
and what we do is we solve problems
through leadership go to
echelonfront.com for details
if you can't get with us
live that's fine go to efonline.com
where we get granular
with these things on a regular basis
where you want to talk to me
you want to interact with me go to
yeponline.com i
you will you will ask me questions me on
a
zoom call you want to talk to dave you
want to ask him something
go to efonline.com you will interact
with him you will ask him questions he
will give you answers
that's what we do on that channel
there's a bunch of training on that
channel
there's a forum on that channel so go to
ef on if
online.com for that
we also have the muster coming up in
phoenix arizona september 16th and 17th
and then dallas texas
december 3rd and 4th check extreme
extreme ownership.com for details
we've we're going to be doing these
looks like with social distancing
so there's going to be less seats
available which means they're going to
sell out faster
we have ef overwatch which is
our placement firm we're
taking people from the military and
placing them into businesses
so if you are a vet looking for
work or you are a company looking for
leaders to come into your company that
understand the principles that we talk
about here go to eforewatch.com
if you want to help out veterans around
the world
service members around the world go to
america's mightywarriors.org that is
mark lee's mom mama lee
helping all service people out
you can go there and you can either
donate or you can get involved
and if you just
can't get enough of my in terminable
tirades or you needs a little bit more
of
echo charles's preposterous postulations
or maybe you just like to hear one more
of dave's jangling juxtapositions
then you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter instagram and on facebook
dave is at david burke david r burke
b-e-r-k-e echo is that echo charles and
i am at jocko willing and of course
thanks to all the men
and women in uniform who allow us to
live
our lives the way we want to and that
is in glorious freedom
and to the police and law enforcement
and firefighters and paramedics and emts
and dispatchers and correctional
officers and border patrol
and secret service thanks to all of you
for protecting us and for keeping our
nation a nation of law
and order not a nation of chaos and
anarchy
and to everyone else out there
just just remember that the effect on
most men of the impact of battle
is to cause them to want to do nothing
and it's the same thing with the slings
and arrows of life we get
pushed toward inaction and
inactivity and indolence
and the solution to that is that a
determined
effort must be exerted
to accomplish things to accomplish
tasks and that is on you
and you know what that means it means
get out there
and get after it and until next time
this is dave and echo and jocko
out